J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Salut tout le monde. On se retrouve pour parler d'un sujet que je vous promets depuis déjà longtemps : le TDAH, qui est donc le trouble du déficit de l'attention avec ou sans hyperactivité.
On est déjà au 92e épisode de ce podcast et au fil des années, j'ai eu la chance de recevoir des experts et des expertes en ce qui concerne la neurodiversité, mais on a surtout parlé d'autisme.
Je pense par exemple à des Julie Dachez, Alistair et Marco Di Luca. Mais évidemment, il y a d'autres façons d'incarner cette neurodiversité et le TDAH est un exemple vraiment incontournable.
Donc il était temps de faire lumière dessus. Il y a beaucoup de clichés sur le TDAH, beaucoup d'idées très réduites sur ce que ça peut donner au quotidien et comment ça fonctionne réellement.
Et c'est pour ça que je suis vraiment très content d'avoir pu me poser pendant deux heures. Oui, oui, cet épisode est un petit peu plus long que d'habitude.
Il y avait vraiment beaucoup à en dire. J'ai pu donc me poser pendant deux heures avec un neurologue. Il est incontournable sur la scène du TDAH à Bruxelles. On a pu
prendre le temps de rectifier les idées reçues, explorer ce qui se passe dans nos petites cervelles de TDAH. Et
vous vous en doutez, on a aussi parlé de questions plus sociétales, des enjeux de culpabilisation et de stigmatisation des personnes concernées,
ainsi que de la piteuse situation de la petite Belgique.
Vous aurez compris évidemment qu'informer les gens au sujet de la neurodiversité est très important pour moi et donc j'espère que vous apprendrez plein de choses.
Bonne écoute. J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec Philippe Violon. Bonjour Philippe.
Bonjour.
Philippe, est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter pour celles et ceux qui ne vous connaissent pas encore ?
Alors, je m'appelle Philippe Violon. Comme vous l'avez dit, je suis neurologue et je suis, depuis quelques années, spécialiste en prise en charge du TDAH chez l'adulte.
Très bien. Et vous officiez donc ici à Bruxelles, à Psy Pluriel, à Uccle.
J'officie effectivement à Psy Pluriel à Uccle, qui est la partie consultation d'un hôpital connu dans le monde psychiatrique, l'hôpital Fond'Roy, qui fait lui-même partie d'un réseau qui est le réseau Epsylon.
Voilà. Et vous êtes actif donc dans les hôpitaux publics depuis, vous disiez, plus de vingt-cinq ans.
J'ai travaillé effectivement les hôpitaux publics bruxellois, je n'y travaille plus et j'y ai travaillé vingt-cinq ans en y faisant essentiellement de la neurologie générale.
Voilà, et vous disiez donc, ça, c'est la partie clinique de votre activité. Il y a également une partie de recherche, alors ?
Oh, j'ai fait de la recherche, mais il y a très très longtemps, quand j'étais encore tout jeune médecin à l'hôpital Erasme, mais sur des domaines qui n'ont rien à voir, puisque c'était le domaine des tumeurs cérébrales.
Et puis que j'ai quitté très, très jeune. J'ai travaillé dans les hôpitaux publics bruxellois. J'y ai été très fidèle pendant longtemps et j'ai été chef de service un moment.
Et puis, je me suis petit à petit intéressé au TDAH, par les hasards de la vie que je pourrais vous raconter si vous le désirez.
J'ai fait un master complémentaire. Le TDAH a pris toute la place dans mon activité professionnelle et c'est le cas maintenant depuis à peu près trois ans.
Mh. Mh. Donc c'est vraiment votre spécialité. On aura l'occasion de reparler un petit peu du marché des soins de santé et du fait que c'est la spécialité de
pas tant de médecins que ça, malheureusement, en Belgique, en Belgique francophone en particulier.
Vous avez dit donc neurologue. Est-ce que vous pourriez un petit peu nous rappeler ce qui fait la distinction pour les patients qui donc ont un TDAH entre aller consulter un neurologue et consulter un psychiatre, par exemple ?
Alors, ce qui fait la distinction, ce qui ne faisait pas la distinction, et ce qui, peut-être dans les années à venir, ne la fera de nouveau plus, puisqu'il y a trente ans, les neurologues et les psychiatres étaient neuropsychiatres.
Ah bah voilà.
C'était une spécialité commune. Et, avant que je ne commence, avant que je ne reçoive moi-même mon titre de neurologue,
il y a eu un split qui était, finalement, un désir des associations professionnelles entre neurologues et psychiatres, le neurologue s'occupant normalement
des pathologies du système nerveux, c'est-à-dire cerveau, moelle épinière, nerfs périphériques, dans son acception physique : maladie de Parkinson, maladie d'Alzheimer, sclérose en plaques, épilepsie, migraine, etc.
Les psychiatres s'occupant des troubles mentaux. Et puis, on se retrouve avec le TDAH,
Ouais, c'était un peu l'intersection.
Voilà, dans une intersection qui fait que aujourd'hui, avec l'avancée de la science de l'imagerie cérébrale fonctionnelle et de toute une série de choses, on va peut-être
recréer une spécialité qui s'appelle la neuropsychiatrie.
Ah oui, je pense effectivement que—
Mais je pense qu'on peut faire un autre débat sur le sujet.
Voilà, en effet. Je pense en effet que le marché des soins de santé ou les spécialisations sur le TDAH en particulier aura beaucoup l'occasion d'évoluer dans les années à venir.
Alors donc, on s'approche, hein, du sujet dont on va parler aujourd'hui, le trouble du déficit de l'attention avec ou sans hyperactivité, voilà.
Je l'avais en anglais dans ma tête.
Moi-même, j'arrive pas à le prononcer.
Ah bah voilà.
Vous inquiétez pas.
Eh bien, donc on va définir un petit peu ce terme dans un instant. Je vais y arriver un petit peu de biais, par une autre question.
Est-ce que vous auriez tendance à dire que ce trouble est bien nommé ? Est-ce que quand on désigne les individus qui ont un TDAH et qu'on dit : « Ces gens ont un déficit de l'attention.
» Est-ce que c'est le bon terme ? Est-ce qu'on résume bien le trouble avec ce nom-là ?
Vous rentrez directement dans le dur du débat—
Mais oui, on y est. Écoutez, on va avoir beaucoup de questions à aborder. Alors, je...
Non, je pense que, je suis pas le seul d'ailleurs,
que c'est probablement une très mauvaise façon de définir un trouble qui, par ailleurs, est extrêmement complexe, mais ce qui est probablement le plus problématique dans ce nom, c'est la notion de déficit.
Bien sûr, il y a des difficultés. Bien sûr, il y a une souffrance, parce que s'il n'y a pas de souffrance, ce n'est pas du domaine médical.
Oui, on peut difficilement dire que quelqu'un est troublé s'il rencontre pas de difficultés.
Il peut troubler, mais il ne peut pas être troublé lui-même. Vous avez tout à fait raison. Et
à ce moment-là, quand on parle de déficit, c'est une connotation déjà extrêmement négative, c'est extrêmement jugeant, y compris pour les patients et pour leur positionnement.
Et on est plus ou moins tous d'accord pour dire que peut-être qu'on aurait plus parlé de troubles de la régulation et pas que de la régulation de l'attention.
On va en parler. C'est un trouble où on a des difficultés à réguler plein de choses plutôt que de dire qu'on est déficitaire.
En fait, beaucoup de patients TDAH ne sont déficitaires en rien, si ce n'est dans leur capacité à réguler et à se réguler.
Alors, effectivement, là, donc, on s'approche directement du dur. Alors, je vais vous poser directement la question. Donc réguler, donc évidemment, l'attention, puisque c'est ce qu'indique le nom.
Les émotions également ? Quoi d'autre ?
Quand on a un TDAH, on a des difficultés, évidemment, à réguler son attention. Déjà, dans les processus attentionnels, il faut faire attention, et c'est ce que j'essaie d'expliquer en consultation, que être attentif,
ce n'est pas qu'être attentif quand on étudie.
Moi, je m'occupe que d'adultes, donc quand on étudie dans des études supérieures ou quand on essaye de réaliser un dossier.
Pouvoir gérer son attention, c'est pouvoir gérer son attention au quotidien, pouvoir gérer son attention quand on fait la vaisselle, pouvoir gérer son attention quand
on fait du bricolage, pouvoir gérer son attention quand on discute avec son conjoint et quand on fait un jeu de société avec ses enfants.
Donc, la notion, déjà, de déficit attentionnel, c'est une notion extrêmement large et qui ne peut pas être présente que, ou qui n'est qu'extrêmement rarement présente dans un cadre qui est purement professionnel ou purement scolaire.
Et puis, on associe aux troubles de l'attention ce qu'on appelle, ce que les neuropsychologues appellent, les troubles des fonctions exécutives et de la mémoire de travail.
Alors, il y a là-dedans, évidemment, des segmentations qui sont des segmentations un petit peu artificielles, parce que dans les
déficits des fonctions exécutives, il y a beaucoup de processus attentionnels et dans la mémoire de travail aussi.
On peut en parler si vous voulez.
Oui. Juste pour revenir sur la notion de la difficulté de l'attention. Ce qu'on remarque déjà, c'est que ça peut prendre des formes très diverses.
Voilà, j'ai en tête des patients qui peuvent, par exemple, ne pas réussir à écouter mes podcasts parce que c'est trop long, ils doivent rester concentrés trop longtemps.
Inversement, d'autres qui le font sans difficulté, mais pour qui lire un livre est mission impossible. Donc vraiment, ce qu'on observe déjà, c'est qu'on peut parler d'un spectre.
Alors, on parle certainement d'un spectre. Alors, c'est très intéressant ce que vous dites, parce que
c'est finalement la position de beaucoup de patients qui souffrent d'un TDA, c'est que s'ils ne sont pas capables d'écouter votre podcast, c'est parce qu'ils ont un TDA.
Mais je pense que vous devez avoir de temps en temps des gens que vous interviewez qui sont particulièrement soporifiques.
Et donc, il faut déjà expliquer à un patient qui a un TDA que s'il n'est pas capable d'écouter dans certaines circonstances, c'est peut-être pas uniquement lié qu'à lui.
Mais c'est vrai que de manière générale, il y a des difficultés attentionnelles. Après ça, bien entendu, ces difficultés attentionnelles, elles ont une sévérité.
Il y a des gens qui ont des difficultés attentionnelles très modérées. Il y a des gens qui ont des difficultés attentionnelles beaucoup plus sévères, voire majeures,
avec des domaines dans lesquels ils sont tout à fait capables de prêter attention, voire d'être, ouvrez les guillemets, hyperfocus, fermez les guillemets, et d'autres dans lesquels l'attention échappe complètement.
Et généralement, tous les patients TDAH vous disent : « Dans telles circonstances, je suis capable de maintenir mon attention parfois une demi-heure, une heure, deux heures » et pour certains, plusieurs heures.
C'est d'ailleurs un grand piège diagnostique, en particulier chez l'enfant.
Ah oui, oui. Donc ça, c'est effectivement un autre cliché, finalement, sur lequel je voulais revenir. C'est finalement cette notion que déjà dans l'esprit de beaucoup de gens, c'est un truc de garçon, un truc de petit garçon.
Et souvent, voilà, dans certains discours, on va vraiment parler de ça comme étant un problème, un problème d'enfant, quoi, un problème d'élèves dans une classe.
Et finalement, quand il s'agit de parler des adultes, là, on met ça entre parenthèses. D'où est-ce que ça vient, d'après vous ?
C'est cette idée que c'est un truc d'enfant, un truc de garçon en particulier ?
Vous avez— il y a beaucoup de questions en votre question.
Bien sûr, bien sûr.
La première chose, bah, la description chez l'enfant,
elle date du XVIIIe et même avant, si on cherche dans la littérature, il y a depuis longtemps des descriptions d'enfants qui sont des enfants turbulents, hyperactifs d'un point de vue moteur.
Parfois oppositionnel.
La première chose, c'est que c'est vrai que cette hyperactivité motrice, elle a tendance, avec la maturation cérébrale et avec la contrainte sociale, à se réduire avec l'âge.
Et c'est vrai que moi, j'ai rarement des adultes qui se mettent à sauter à quatre pattes sur mon bureau. D'ailleurs, je pense que je n'en ai jamais eu.
Mh.
Ni à courir dans la pièce. Par contre, j'ai des adultes qui bougent sur leur chaise, qui bougent leurs mains, qui tripotent la boîte de mouchoirs qui est devant eux. Donc, il y a déjà—
Un petit biais de sélection dans le sens où on a en tête des traits de comportement qui sont plutôt observés chez les enfants.
Et donc, comme on ne les voit plus trop, voilà, sauter sur le bureau, comme vous dites, à l'âge adulte, on se dit : « Bah non, c'est pas ça. »
C'était le grand principe.
Ouais.
C'était le grand principe. Et puis, par ailleurs, il y avait un deuxième biais de sélection qui était le biais de sélection qui répond à votre autre question, qui est que on a longtemps identifié les TDAH
que par leur hyperactivité motrice ou leur impulsivité.
Et c'est la raison d'ailleurs pour laquelle il y a globalement quatre fois plus de petits garçons que de petites filles qui sont diagnostiqués avec un TDA, parce que, ben on va beaucoup plus—
Mh.
Entamer une démarche quand il y a un petit garçon qui, excusez-moi l'expression, emmerde tout le monde, y compris l'institutrice, les parents, qui tient pas,
assis, qui va renverser son plumier, qui va ennuyer son camarade et qui va ennuyer les parents à la maison.
Et là, il y a quand même une dimension sociétale puisque sans doute, je parle avec prudence, mais sans doute qu'il y a des contraintes plus importantes dans l'éducation des petites filles pour être très très sages.
Chez les garçons, peut-être un peu moins, mais peut-être que c'est ça qui joue aussi.
Il y a à la fois des phénomènes sociétaux et des phénomènes probablement génétiques.
Ok. Donc—
Qui font que les petites filles vont développer plus fréquemment, et ce n'est absolument pas dans cent pour cent des cas, des formes plus inattentives.
Ok.
Avec en plus la contrainte sociale, évidemment, qui font que elles vont se retrouver au fond de la classe ou pas au fond de la classe, peut-être ne parlant pas beaucoup, mais n'arrivant pas à suivre quand elles sont petites les cours.
Et juste, bah,
c'est ce que je vois fréquemment dans mes consultations, hein, mes patientes adultes qui me disent : « Bah oui, bah moi, je pouvais être considérée comme la petite fille qui, voilà,
faisait ce qu'elle pouvait, mais elle était dans la lune, elle avait même des capacités limitées.
» Voilà. Et après ça, cette proportion, bizarrement, étrangement, devient dans les diagnostics chez l'adulte de cinquante cinquante.
Cinquante pour cent de femmes pour cinquante pour cent d'hommes, parce que, par ailleurs, les femmes ont plus tendance à faire appel à l'aide médicale que les hommes.
Et ça amène à, pas une inversion, mais en tout cas—
Ça rééquilibre le ratio.
Un rééquilibrage de la tendance.
Oui. Et donc vis-à-vis de cette idée que c'est quelque chose qu'on peut parfois trouver dans la littérature scientifique, il y aurait
soixante à septante pour cent des enfants avec un trouble du déficit de l'attention qui le conservent à l'âge adulte.
Vous, vous dites : c'est strictement une question, voilà, un problème dans le diagnostic et que on ne perd pas son TDAH en grandissant.
Alors, ce qui se passe, c'est que le TDAH va évoluer, hein, comme je le disais, en grandissant. Beaucoup de patients jeunes vont
compenser ou vont améliorer certains des symptômes, mais qu'il y a suffisamment de symptômes résiduels pour que le TDAH à l'âge adulte reste extrêmement handicapant.
Dans la dernière version du DSM,
ils en ont d'ailleurs tenu compte puisque dans les critères de cette bible des troubles mentaux que les médecins utilisent, eh bien, on a réduit le nombre de critères nécessaires pour poser le diagnostic à l'âge adulte de,
sur un ensemble de neuf critères pour l'impulsivité, l'hyperactivité, de neuf critères
pour l'inattention, on les a réduits de six à cinq parce qu'on a tenu compte du fait que certains éléments, certains symptômes venaient à disparaître, à s'amender avec l'âge adulte.
Oui. Puisque vous parlez de cette notion de critères de sélection,
c'est souvent en fonction de ça qu'on va agrandir ou diminuer l'estimation du pourcentage de la population qui est concernée par ce trouble-là ou par d'autres troubles.
Si on est particulièrement restrictif et qu'on veut une définition particulièrement stéréotypée, forcément, on tombera sur un pourcentage très faible.
Aujourd'hui, avec donc cette dernière définition, telle que définie dans le DSM,
aujourd'hui, on estime à combien de personnes, voilà, à l'échelle de la population, quel pourcentage de personnes qui sont concernées ?
C'est amusant parce que, que ce soit chez l'enfant ou chez l'adulte, il y a une variabilité extrême—
Forcément.
Selon les pays. Alors d'abord, on a des chiffres globalement que dans très peu de pays. On a des chiffres que dans moins de vingt pays.
Parce que c'est sûr que si vous mourez de faim, que vous êtes en pleine guerre ou que vous n'arrivez pas à vous chauffer, le TDAH n'est pas la priorité.
Il faut un certain niveau de privilège pour avoir le temps de s'en préoccuper.
Il faut un certain niveau de privilège. Il faut un système de santé qui fonctionne bien. Il faut avoir—
Pour avoir l'occasion de s'en préoccuper.
Une société qui soit structurée, qui prenne soin de l'autre.
Et donc pour revenir donc à ce que vous disiez sur les pourcentages.
C'est très variable. Alors chez l'enfant, on estime aujourd'hui à sept, huit pour cent. Aux États-Unis, les derniers chiffres du Center for Disease Control sont au-delà de dix pour cent.
Ok.
Dans certaines études européennes et dans certains pays, on est plutôt aux environs de cinq, six. Mais globalement, si chez l'enfant, on prend sept, huit pour cent de la population, on n'est pas très loin.
Chez l'adulte, aux environs des trois pour cent, mais de nouveau, avec des grandes variabilités.
Mh. Mh.
Voilà. Mais est-ce que c'est parce qu'on perd 50 % de la population à 18 ans ? Probablement pas. Probablement parce qu'on s'intéresse moins au TDAH chez l'adulte que chez l'enfant.
Donc il y a plein de biais—
Tout certainement.
Il y a plein d'erreurs qui sont liées au fait qu'on ne connaît pas encore très très bien le TDAH.
C'est sûr. Et encore une fois, ça dépend d'à quel point on est strict vis-à-vis des critères de diagnostic, si on,
si on veut quelque chose de très très stéréotypé ou si au contraire, on a conscience du fait que c'est un spectre et qu'il y a plein de façons différentes de le vivre.
Alors oui et non, si je peux me permettre.
Oui, dites-moi.
Les critères sont extrêmement stricts.
D'accord.
Il y a neuf critères pour l'inattention dans le DSM, neuf critères pour l'impulsivité hyperactivité. Il faut remplir un certain nombre de ces critères, cinq chez l'adulte, six chez l'enfant.
Et donc les critères sont extrêmement stricts. Ce qui va varier dans la prévalence du TDA, d'abord, c'est : est-ce qu'on s'intéresse au TDA ?
Il y a beaucoup de patients adultes qui ont un TDA. Personne n'a jamais évoqué le diagnostic du TDAH chez eux.
C'est déjà le cas en Belgique, on aura l'occasion d'en parler. La situation ici n'est pas idéale non plus.
Donc déjà, pour avoir une prévalence dans une population, il faut qu'on s'intéresse à la problématique. Et puis, il y a la façon de poser le diagnostic.
S'il suffisait, pour poser le diagnostic, de donner une copie de la page du DSM au patient en leur demandant : remplissez-la et en fonction de ça, je vous dirai si oui ou non, vous avez un TDA—
Oui, le test sur Internet quoi finalement.
Ça serait trop simple, le test sur Internet.
Oui, c'est ça. Donc c'est vraiment une question clinique. 'Fin, y a plusieurs facteurs qui entrent en jeu.
Et je dis ça parce que je pense également, voilà, je fais le parallèle à un autre trouble neurodéveloppemental qui est l'autisme, où je sais que par exemple,
voilà, il y a certains chercheurs qui vont défendre des idées, voilà, encore une fois très très stéréotypées et qui, voilà, des enfants qui seraient mutiques, qui auraient des grandes, grandes difficultés de communication.
Et à ce moment-là, on arrive en dessous de 1 % de la population. Inversement, aux États-Unis, il y a effectivement certains hôpitaux où on a fait des grandes,
voilà, des grandes statistiques sur toutes les natalités pendant une période étendue et avec des critères bien élargis.
Et là, on arrive plutôt autour de 6 %. Donc c'est, encore une fois, voilà, un grand niveau de variabilité vis-à-vis de ça.
Je pense que le parallèle avec
les troubles du spectre de l'autisme est excellent pour deux raisons. Ce sont tous les deux des troubles neurodéveloppementaux qui sont liés donc à des problèmes de développement cérébral depuis la naissance.
Donc, ils ont ça en commun. La deuxième chose, c'est qu'on découvre récemment, depuis quelques années, qu'il y a un lien fort entre le TDA et les troubles du spectre de l'autisme.
C'est-à-dire que beaucoup de patients chez qui on diagnostique primairement un trouble du spectre de l'autisme ont un TDA, à peu près un sur sept.
Mh.
Et à l'inverse, chez les patients adultes qui ont un trouble du déficit de l'attention, la probabilité d'avoir un trouble du spectre de l'autisme est beaucoup plus élevée que dans la population en général.
Et in fine, vous avez raison, on est passé en quelques dizaines d'années d'une évaluation pour les troubles du spectre de l'autisme du type un cas sur deux mille personnes à un sur une cinquantaine.
Oui.
Pour deux raisons, probablement. Il y a un petit peu d'augmentation des troubles du spectre de l'autisme pour des raisons multiples et diverses qu'on ne va pas discuter ici.
Et la deuxième chose, on accepte maintenant qu'il puisse y avoir beaucoup de patients qui ont un trouble du spectre de l'autisme adulte et qui sont avec de bons, voire d'excellents quotients intellectuels.
Des capacités d'autonomie, de se débrouiller dans la vie sans un—
Parfaitement autonomes, avec une activité professionnelle, parfois avec une vie familiale, avec une vie sociale.
Parfois avec un podcast. Donc oui—
Et parfois avec des podcasts.
Dans l'occurrence, moi, je suis autiste TDAH. Donc vraiment, je suis cette personne-là.
Je vous remercie d'illustrer mon propos.
Mais donc effectivement, ça illustre le— 'fin, on parle souvent des mêmes personnes quoi. Souvent, quand quelqu'un est autiste, c'est vraiment pas rare qu'il soit aussi concerné par le TDAH.
Y a d'autres troubles hein, troubles vis-à-vis de l'anxiété, vis-à-vis du, parfois, du—
Bien sûr.
Du—
Anxiété, dépression—
De l'hyperendorsif, comme ça, oui.
Toute une série de problématiques. On parle de TDAH complexe,
mais il y a— la pratique quotidienne et les études scientifiques permettent globalement de dire que prendre en charge un patient adulte, et de nouveau, je m'occupe que de patients adultes, donc je vais parler que des adultes,
avec un TDA dans
septante, septante-cinq pour cent des cas, c'est aussi s'occuper de tout ce qui vient avec le TDA, dont certains patients ont conscience et d'autres n'ont pas conscience en fonction de leur parcours médical, personnel, etc.
Et donc ne s'intéresser qu'au TDA—
C'est ça.
Ça devient aujourd'hui très compliqué.
'Fin là, pendant longtemps, je pense que beaucoup de praticiens avaient tendance à chercher un diagnostic,
alors qu'en fait, finalement, comme vous dites, on se rend compte qu'on peut tout à fait les empiler, voilà, des patients qui ont trois, quatre diagnostics
séparés, c'est absolument pas contradictoire.
Et aussi, une autre difficulté,
ça, je pense que vous avez sans doute souvent l'occasion de l'observer, c'est le patient à qui on va, voilà, faire la liste des critères diagnostics et qui vont simplement répondre : « Non, mais tout le monde est comme ça.
C'est— 'fin, c'est tout à fait normal d'avoir des difficultés pour oublier ses affaires, pour procrastiner, etc. » Et tout le monde— ils vont se dire : « Mais non, mais tout le monde est comme ça. »
Je pense qu'on pourrait faire Septante Minutes sur les différentes problématiques rencontrées dans le TDAH et vous avez totalement raison.
Mais globalement, on sait maintenant pourquoi. Et on le sait depuis quelques années, mais on le sait encore beaucoup mieux depuis 2023.
On sait pourquoi quoi ?
On sait pourquoi quand on a un TDAH, on s'entend fréquemment dire : « Mais tu sais, moi aussi, de temps en temps, je procrastine.
Mais tu sais, moi, de temps en temps aussi, je suis impulsif. »
C'est ça.
« Mais tu sais, moi aussi, de temps en temps, j'oublie des choses. Mais moi aussi, tu sais, de temps en temps, je n'écoute pas.
» On le sait parce qu'on connaît depuis 2023, depuis quelques années, mais avec une publication fondamentale en 2023 sur la génétique du TDA.
Et cette publication sur la génétique du TDA nous a montré que, un, contrairement à beaucoup de maladies, ce n'était pas un gène, c'est-à-dire un petit morceau de chromosome qui était touché sur un chromosome.
C'est le cas dans certains cancers du sein héréditaire, par exemple, ou dans la mucoviscidose, mais que le TDA, les symptômes du TDA impliquaient plusieurs chromosomes,
plus de septante gènes, c'est-à-dire plus de septante morceaux de chromosomes qui vont coder pour des protéines.
Et sur ces septante gènes, il peut y avoir plus de sept mille variations différentes. C'est comme si vous pouviez m'enregistrer avec sept mille types de micros différents.
Tous les micros permettent de m'enregistrer et ces sept mille variations génétiques différentes sont toutes responsables de certains symptômes qu'on retrouve dans le TDA.
Et pourquoi on parle de variations génétiques ? On parle de variants génétiques. En fait, parce que ce sont certains types de mutations, mais qui sont rentrés il y a plusieurs centaines ou plusieurs milliers d'années dans la population générale.
Et donc, la grande majorité de la population humaine possède certains de ces variants génétiques du TDA, ce qui explique que la majorité de la population est un peu inattentive—
D'accord.
Est un peu hyperactive, est un peu impulsive—
C'est intéressant.
Est un peu procrastinatrice.
Est-ce que de la même manière que c'est très irritant quand les gens disent : « Non, mais tout le monde est un petit peu autiste », ce qui est faux et absolument faux,
là, vous me dites que par contre, c'est tout à fait légitime de dire : « Tout le monde est un petit peu TDAH. »
Non.
Non, non. Ah voilà.
Tout le monde n'est absolument pas un petit peu TDAH. C'est par exemple une erreur qu'on voit souvent dans les réseaux sociaux.
Tout le monde ou beaucoup de gens, la majorité de la population, présentent certains symptômes communs à l'ensemble de la population et présents aussi dans le TDAH.
Oui, d'accord, ok.
Le fait d'avoir un TDAH, c'est finalement la surexpression, l'expression trop intense, l'expression trop fréquente, les problèmes de régulation de ces symptômes présents dans l'ensemble de la population.
Et en fait, ça s'explique— ça va être très facile à comprendre pour vos auditeurs. Ça s'explique très simplement grâce aujourd'hui à ce qu'on appelle le score polygénique.
Le score polygénique, c'est combien vous avez de variants dans votre code génétique. C'est comme quand on boit un verre de vin.
Si vous buvez un verre de vin ou deux verres de vin, pour peu qu'on vous ait mis le vin, y a pas de problème. Mais si vous buvez trois bouteilles, ça va vraiment poser problème.
Si vous avez un peu d'hyperactivité, un peu d'inattention, un peu de procrastination, un peu de difficultés organisationnelles, ça ne pose pas de problème. C'est pas un TDA.
Vous n'êtes pas un peu TDA. Vous avez des symptômes communs à l'ensemble de la population.
Si vous présentez ces problèmes attentionnels de fonctions exécutives, de mémoire de travail, de manière extrêmement intense, quotidienne et dans toute une série de domaines de votre vie,
le travail, la famille, les loisirs, les amis, là, vous avez un TDA.
Vous faites partie des 3 % d'adultes TDA.
Alors, on rentre dans le dur, hein, avec ces notions de mutations génétiques. Donc si on revient alors sur la définition neurologique, la définition bien biologique du trouble du déficit de l'attention,
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans le cerveau d'une personne qui est concernée ?
Alors déjà, il y a pas de définition biologique.
D'accord.
Parce que c'est une question que beaucoup de patients posent. « Ah ben docteur, est-ce que vous pourriez me faire une prise de sang ?
Docteur, est-ce qu'on peut faire un test génétique ? Ah docteur, est-ce qu'on pourrait faire un électroencéphalogramme ?
Docteur, est-ce qu'on pourrait faire une résonance magnétique pour voir mon TDA ? » Non, il y a pas de définition. La définition est une définition purement clinique.
Comportementale.
Comportementale et de fonctionnement mental qui, effectivement, va permettre de poser le diagnostic de TDA. Mais par contre, on sait effectivement que dans le TDA, il y a un neurotransmetteur,
c'est-à-dire une substance qui permet aux neurones, aux cellules cérébrales, de communiquer entre elles, en particulier la dopamine, qui va être impliquée dans ces troubles attentionnels des fonctions exécutives qu'on rencontre dans le TDAH.
Pour rappel, contrairement à ce que beaucoup de mes patients me disent : « Ah oui, docteur, j'en ai entendu parler dans les réseaux sociaux.
Donc la dopamine, c'est une hormone et c'est l'hormone du bonheur. » Non.
C'est la sérotonine plutôt.
C'est un neurotransmetteur.
Et dans ce cadre-ci, la dopamine est vraiment très très impliquée dans l'activation, notamment vers la récompense et le fait de pouvoir commencer une tâche, se maintenir dans une tâche et terminer une tâche.
Récompense qui s'inscrit aussi dans un processus, finalement, entre gros guillemets, d'addiction, dans le sens où on l'a eu une fois, on a envie que ça recommence.
On aimerait bien que la prochaine— on a envie de recommencer le procédé qui nous a permis d'arriver à cette dopamine et donc on va le refaire, on va se dire que c'est plutôt un procédé sympa, on va le refaire.
Alors effectivement, c'est un des mécanismes pour parler des addictions. Ben, il y a plein d'addictions dans le TDA. Ce qui veut pas dire—
On va en parler, ouais.
Ce qui veut pas dire que parce qu'on a un TDA, on a une addiction. Comme il y a plein de gens qui sont en prison qui ont un TDA, mais ça veut pas dire que quand on vient me voir en consultation,
j'appelle obligatoirement le fourgon pour mettre le patient en prison.
Mais oui, oui, un des processus de l'addiction est lié à des problèmes de gestion des circuits de la récompense.
Oui.
Notamment, pas que.
Dites-moi, donc vous arrivez donc avec l'importance de la dopamine dans, voilà, le fonctionnement d'un cerveau, une personne qui a un TDA.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe exactement vis-à-vis de la dopamine ? On parle parfois d'hyposensibilité. C'est de ça dont il s'agit ?
Alors, globalement, et ça reste relativement caricatural parce que la recherche est en cours. Il y a un déficit dans la concentration de dopamine dans certaines zones spécifiques du cerveau,
notamment dans certaines zones situées à l'avant du cerveau, les zones qu'on appelle préfrontales, vraiment au niveau du front.
Et des zones, je vais vous épargner les noms. Et ce sont des zones qui sont intimement liées justement à ces fonctions exécutives, à la capacité de démarrer une tâche, de se maintenir à une tâche,
de s'inhiber, c'est-à-dire de s'empêcher d'être attiré par son GSM, le livre qu'il faut ranger, le truc auquel on vient de penser,
de pouvoir mémoriser les éléments qui sont fondamentaux pour finaliser la tâche et puis, in fine, arriver au bout de son objectif.
Et ça, ça dépend évidemment de l'ensemble du cerveau. Hein, parce que, je veux dire, si on enlève 90 % du cerveau de quelqu'un et qu'on lui garde qu'une partie de ses lobes frontaux, je peux vous assurer, il va pas fonctionner.
Mais parce que...
Vous avez essayé ?
Je peux pas vous en parler aujourd'hui. Mais dès que le micro sera coupé. Mais notamment cette zone-là, cette zone du cortex préfrontal qu'on appelle dorsolatéral, est très impliquée dans les fonctions exécutives.
Il y a un déficit de dopamine et c'est là-dessus que joue la majorité des traitements du TDA, en tout cas les traitements de première ligne.
Ils vont augmenter la concentration de dopamine, notamment dans ces zones.
Donc c'est vraiment une question de la présence, la quantité de dopamine et c'est pas tellement une question d'ordre de sensibilité, d'hyposensibilité.
C'est probablement une question beaucoup plus vaste de sensibilité, de nombre de récepteurs à la dopamine, de quantité de dopamine et surtout, maintenant, on le sait depuis quelques années, c'est une question de réseaux cérébraux.
On a longtemps pensé le cerveau comme étant une espèce de puzzle avec des pièces et chaque pièce a sa fonction spécifique.
Et aujourd'hui, grâce aux techniques qu'on appelle l'imagerie cérébrale fonctionnelle, où on peut voir des zones du cerveau occupées à fonctionner ou occupées à fonctionner de manière prédominante, on sait qu'il y a
notamment trois réseaux fondamentaux
qui sont impliqués dans le TDA.
Un dont on parle énormément, qui est le réseau mode par défaut. Vous verrez, si je vous l'explique, c'est extrêmement facile à comprendre.
Et il y a surtout un déficit, il y a un déficit de dopamine, mais il y a un déficit d'équilibre entre des réseaux cérébraux.
Mmh. C'est intéressant puisque il y a quelques instants, vous m'expliquiez que vous refusiez à vos patients les diagnostics via prise de sang, via scanner, etc.
Là, vous me dites qu'avec une IRM, on observe des différences quand même.
Avec beaucoup d'IRM chez beaucoup de patients—
Oui.
...chez lesquels on moyennise des résultats et pour lesquels on fait des études statistiques—
D'accord, ok.
...complexes qui font que ce qui est vrai pour des groupes est toujours, en tout cas aujourd'hui, hein, ce que je dis aujourd'hui sera probablement tout à fait faux dans cinq ou dix ans.
Ça périme dans une semaine, ouais.
Dans une semaine, j'espère pas. Mais en tout cas dans cinq ou dix ans. Donc à titre individuel, oui, non, c'est absolument non démontrable.
C'est, voilà, on peut pas encore se dépendre, voilà, d'une IRM pour faire un diagnostic. Et l'autre point sur lequel je voudrais revenir, c'est que vous disiez donc l'importance du cortex préfrontal dans tout ça.
Il y a une différence importante puisque c'est neurodéveloppemental. Il y a une différence importante dans le développement du cortex préfrontal chez les garçons et chez les filles.
Il y a des différences, et pas rien que dans le cortex préfrontal chez les garçons et chez les filles, et il y a des différences entre les TDAH et les gens qui n'ont pas de TDAH.
Oui.
Et entre les gens qui ont un trouble du spectre de l'autisme et les gens qui n'en ont pas. Ce qui clôt par ailleurs, si je peux me permettre, certains débats
de certains médias internationaux, puisque beaucoup de gens ont entendu parler d'un article ou de plusieurs articles récents,
notamment dans le New York Times, qui mettaient en doute la validité même du diagnostic du TDAH et de l'existence du TDAH.
Non, il y a des démonstrations qui sont des démonstrations en imagerie cérébrale, génétique, etc., etc. Mais pas à titre individuel.
C'est ça. Alors donc, cette difficulté de régulation, donc de la dopamine
dans certains réseaux, comme vous le disiez, concrètement, voilà, on a parlé des difficultés, des dysfonctions exécutives, on a parlé de la difficulté au niveau de l'attention, des émotions.
Au quotidien, voilà, si on plongeait un petit peu dans ce que ça donne, les dysfonctions exécutives dans le quotidien chez vos patients, à quoi ça ressemble ?
Vous savez, moi, j'ai tendance à utiliser une métaphore que vous ne retrouverez dans aucun critère international, qui est celle de la dispersion de la poignée de sable.
Si vous allez à la mer,
que le sable est sec, avec de fins grains, et que vous prenez une poignée de sable extrêmement sec, vous la lancez en l'air et là, tout d'un coup, vous avez une bourrasque,
le sable va partir dans tous les sens, y compris d'ailleurs dans vos yeux.
Qui va rendre votre vision, et votre vision de vous et de votre environnement, très compliquée. Le TDAH, c'est un peu ça.
C'est pour moi un trouble de la dispersion et un trouble de la régulation. On est dispersé, dérégulé dans ses pensées, avec souvent un excès de pensée, une hyperactivité mentale. On est
dérégulé dans ses comportements, dans sa capacité à se maintenir, à faire quelque chose. On passe,
quand on travaille sur son PC, de son PC à son smartphone, de son smartphone à sa tablette, de sa tablette à la recette de cuisine, et de la recette de cuisine à la dernière idée qu'on vient d'avoir.
On est dispersé et on est surtout dérégulé dans ses émotions. Il y a depuis plusieurs années un débat sur le fait que, en dehors de la triade
inattention, impulsivité — je rappelle, l'impulsivité n'est pas présente chez tout le monde, mais fréquente, même sous des formes mineures — et hyperactivité,
il faut pas ajouter la dysrégulation émotionnelle, c'est-à-dire la difficulté de réguler ses émotions, puisque comme l'attention, comme les comportements impulsifs, comme
l'hyperactivité comportementale et mentale, les émotions, on estime, sont dérégulées chez à peu près trois quarts des patients TDAH adultes.
Ils sont sujets aussi à l'inhibition et vous disiez qu'il y a des difficultés d'inhibition...
Les émotions arrivent plus rapidement, sont plus intenses et sont beaucoup plus difficiles à ramener au point de base, à réguler.
Donc beaucoup de patients TDAH, dès qu'ils sont suractivés, ils racontent : « Je vais rester. Et pourquoi ?
Et pourquoi ? Et pourquoi machin m'a dit ça ? Pourquoi il m'a dit ça ? Mais pourquoi ? Et pourtant, j'ai bien fait.
Pourquoi il m'a dit ça ? » Et que ce soit dans le couple, que ce soit avec les enfants, que ce soit dans le cadre du travail, etc.
Et cette espèce de suractivation émotionnelle va avoir beaucoup de mal à revenir au point de base.
La dysrégulation émotionnelle, selon certains — mais c'est pas moi qui fais
les guidelines, comme on appelle ça, c'est pas moi qui rédige les critères du TDAH — devrait faire partie des critères diagnostics du TDAH, tellement ça semble être
pathognomonique, c'est-à-dire vraiment assez...
Omniprésent.
Présent et avec une certaine spécificité.
Et donc c'est ça qui fait débat pour l'instant. Donc, vous disiez, voilà, cet exemple de personne qui, impulsivement, va avoir envie de passer de son travail sur l'ordinateur à son smartphone, avoir du mal à se retenir, etc.
C'est sans doute là, effectivement, qu'on peut faire un lien très concret avec
la question de la dopamine, puisqu'il y a un petit peu cette idée que plutôt que de travailler sur quelque chose qui donnera une récompense in fine un peu plus loin dans le futur,
au travail, on aura un salaire à la fin du mois, il faut
faire plaisir au patron.
Inversement, prendre son téléphone et regarder TikTok, c'est une récompense immédiate. Vraiment, on est submergé par la dopamine, c'est très intéressant, c'est passionnant et ça nous... voilà.
Oui, parce que caricaturalement, la dopamine, c'est très simple à comprendre. Elle a un rôle qui est fondamental, qui est le rôle de se mettre en mouvement, mentalement ou physiquement,
pour atteindre son objectif, c'est-à-dire sa récompense, et y arriver.
Et donc il y a des récompenses qui sont immédiates et qui sont très très faciles à atteindre. Scroller sur TikTok. Il y a des récompenses qui sont extrêmement puissantes.
Elles peuvent être sexuelles, elles peuvent être liées à la consommation. Et il y a des récompenses qui sont soit de très faible niveau, soit très lointaines.
Dans le temps en particulier, ouais.
Alors, une récompense de faible niveau, c'est faire la vaisselle. C'est quoi votre récompense quand vous avez fait la vaisselle ?
C'est d'avoir une vaisselle propre. Waouh. Ça, pour un patient TDAH, je peux vous assurer, le niveau de récompense, il est tellement faible qu'il y a pas assez de dopamine pour l'amener à faire la vaisselle.
Et s'il commence à faire la vaisselle, ou elle commence à faire la vaisselle, on va faire deux assiettes, puis on va penser à autre chose, puis on va dire : « Ah oui, mais je dois aller chercher les pâtes.
Ah non, mais je dois appeler mon pote machin. » Et voilà. Et les récompenses lointaines, typiquement dans les études supérieures, il y a des récompenses lointaines.
Ce qui veut pas dire que les patients TDAH ne font pas d'études supérieures, loin de là. Mais
quand on doit expliquer à un
jeune patient de dix-huit ans, dix-neuf ans, qui a un TDA fort marqué, que
il va devoir réussir,
après son blocus, son premier examen
de la première session
pour peut-être ne pas avoir d'examen en deuxième session de sa première année pour réussir son bachelier, ce qui va lui permettre de réussir son master, ce qui va lui permettre d'avoir son diplôme, ce qui va lui permettre de travailler.
Je peux vous assurer que c'est tellement lointain
pour un patient TDA, que c'est d'une abstraction totale. C'est comme si on lui montrait un tableau abstrait en lui disant : « Mais tu vois, là, les vaches, les arbres, les pommes et les poires ?
» Ben non, il voit rien du tout.
Oui.
J'ai en tête certains récits de personnes donc concernées par le TDAH, qui me parlent
d'un instant où elles doivent donc travailler, par exemple, effectivement, dans le domaine universitaire, sur un mémoire ou sur quelque chose qui est un petit peu
éloigné dans le temps.
Ces personnes me parlent d'être allongées sur leur lit, fixer le plafond en se disant : « Il faudrait que je me mette au boulot, mais je n'y arrive pas ».
C'est même pas qu'elles sont tentées d'ouvrir TikTok ou des choses comme ça. Elles sont vraiment allongées sur leur lit à se dire : « Il faudrait que je le fasse, mais j'arrive pas à m'y mettre ».
Et alors, on parle parfois de cette paralysie TDAH. Est-ce que c'est concrètement quelque chose que vous observez chez vos patients ?
Est-ce que c'est un phénomène connu ?
Alors, l'exemple que vous donnez, il est passionnant, il est extrêmement fréquent et il doit toujours être disséqué.
Ça, c'est le médecin qui parle. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'évidemment, dans le TDA, il y a effectivement de la procrastination et ça peut être une procrastination extrême.
J'ai une patiente récemment qui me disait : « Vous savez, docteur, avant les traitements, je me rappelle quand j'allais vers mon canapé et que je laissais tomber un mouchoir,
je m'asseyais dans mon canapé et je pouvais regarder ce mouchoir pendant une demi-heure.
Je savais que je devais me lever, le prendre, le mettre dans la poubelle, ce qui m'aurait pris facilement douze secondes, mais c'était juste pas possible.
C'était pas possible. Je ne pouvais pas me lever, ramasser le mouchoir et le mettre dans la poubelle. » Donc l'exemple que vous donnez est exactement le même.
Il y a un problème du circuit de la récompense, parce que de nouveau, la récompense pour se lever, ramasser un mouchoir et le mettre dans la poubelle, la récompense est faible.
Et par ailleurs, l'hyperactivité mentale, le fait d'être absorbé par ses pensées va évidemment ne pas améliorer la procrastination.
Mais n'oublions pas que dans le TDA, il y a beaucoup de problèmes associés. Et un des problèmes associés le plus fréquent, ce sont les troubles anxieux.
Beaucoup de gens, beaucoup de patients passent la porte d'une consultation TDA en se demandant, par définition, puisque ça s'appelle consultation TDA, s'ils ont un TDA,
mais ils ne passent que très rarement la porte pour se demander si en même temps, ils ont un autre problème, sauf s'il a été préalablement diagnostiqué.
Et énormément de patients, on estime un adulte sur deux dans les études récentes, présentent un trouble anxieux, et en particulier ce qu'on appelle un trouble anxieux généralisé.
Et dans les troubles anxieux, on a peur. On a peur de plein de choses. Peur, pas au sens de se mettre en position fœtale.
On craint, on s'inquiète, on se crée des scénarios catastrophes, on se crée des scénarios négatifs.
Beaucoup de patients qui ont un TDA ont dû s'entendre très tôt dire : « N'est pas malin » ou « A du potentiel, mais ne fout rien, est fainéant, n'utilise pas ses capacités, n'arrivera jamais à rien.
» Ces jugements de valeur sont souvent internalisés et ils font leur réapparition quand il y a un effort important à faire.
Donc, on procrastine devant ses études, non seulement parce qu'on a un TDA et qu'on a un problème de fonction exécutive et d'initiation de la tâche, on procrastine parce qu'on se dit depuis des années qu'on est con, qu'on n'est pas capable.
Problème d'estime de soi.
Qu'on n'y arrivera pas, on a un problème d'estime de soi. Et parfois, on procrastine parce que juste, on a peur. Vous savez, j'ai fait de l'entraînement mental de sportifs de très haut niveau, je les citerai pas, il y a un certain nombre d'années.
En tennis, on voyait ça régulièrement. Un tennisman, ou une tenniswoman de très haut niveau,
quand il joue contre quelqu'un, ou elle joue contre quelqu'un de bien mieux classé, il y en a un certain nombre qui vont jouer à fond, ils vont s'y mettre à fond parce que c'est quoi le problème ?
Le problème, c'est que s'ils perdent, c'est pas grave, ils vont perdre contre quelqu'un qui a un cinquante classements supérieurs au sien.
Mais ces mêmes tennismen ou women qui vont jouer contre quelqu'un de bien moins classé, avec les parents qui regardent, avec le coach qui regarde, avec la fédération qui regarde, tout d'un coup, ils se mettent à plus jouer, ils font n'importe quoi.
Et après ça, ils se font engueuler. Comme les étudiants. T'as perdu parce que t'as rien foutu. Beaucoup d'étudiants préfèrent
inconsciemment perdre, rater leurs examens parce qu'ils n'ont rien foutu, plutôt que de s'y mettre à fond, rater éventuellement un examen, ce qui arrive à tout le monde, et avoir la confirmation de ce qu'on leur a toujours dit : « T'es con. »
C'est ça. Donc finalement, l'environnement, le regard des autres, le discours des autres sur nos propres capacités est également un facteur important dans cette paralysie.
Le TDA, la façon dont il s'exprime est, j'en suis persuadé, la résultante d'une composante génétique et ce qu'on appelle environnementale.
Et dans l'environnement, il y a la vie d'aujourd'hui, mais il y a aussi la vie passée, son parcours de vie en tant qu'enfant, en tant qu'ado, bien sûr.
Oui, oui. Donc, voilà, on a discuté l'espace d'un instant de cette notion de paralysie. Un autre cliché, une autre dysfonction exécutive qui revient souvent, c'est
la procrastination, je vais mettre ça avec, mais également le fait d'arriver souvent en retard.
Donc ça, c'est très compatible avec cette idée du fait que abandonner ce qu'on est en train de faire et qui est très passionnant et qui nous donne peut-être de la dopamine, plutôt que de se dire
: « Si je pars maintenant, j'arriverai à l'avance.
» Bon, une récompense qui est pas ouf.
Souvent, les retards, c'est même au-delà de ça, c'est...
on a une mémoire, enfin, on a plein de mémoires différentes, mais on a une mémoire qui s'appelle la mémoire de travail, qui est une mémoire courte, et dans laquelle il se passe plein de choses.
Et notamment, il y a un langage interne qui se développe en mémoire de travail, qui fait que si on travaille ou si on doit aller à un rendez-vous médical ou podcast, on se dit : « OK, alors, je dois encore faire ça, ça et ça.
Je vois que je dois prendre ma voiture ou les transports en commun ou mon vélo. Il va me falloir autant de temps.
» Par ailleurs, il y a une partie visuelle dans cette mémoire de travail qui va nous permettre de visualiser, si on fait une recette, le fait que
pour faire la recette des crêpes, on a besoin de farine, peut-être
de sel, peut-être de lait, d'eau, et puis après ça, d'un peu de sucre.
Si on n'a pas de bonne mémoire de travail, on va pas avoir
toute cette capacité à utiliser les éléments de notre environnement, à les processer mentalement, c'est-à-dire à vraiment les organiser mentalement pour planifier, structurer, organiser notre futur.
Organiser notre futur, le futur, il est à une demi-heure, il est à une heure et il est à dix ans. On parle de temps en temps, dans certains articles du TDA, d'aveuglement du futur.
Oui, tout à fait. Time blindness.
Voilà, exactement. C'est plus joli en anglais.
Oui, c'est celui du temps, oui.
Mais vous avez raison. Et ça, c'est probablement lié notamment à des altérations en mémoire de travail.
Mais docteur, le nombre de fois que j'entends ça. Docteur, trois quarts d'heure avant mon départ, je me suis dit : il faut que je me prépare.
J'ai commencé à me préparer, j'ai pris mon manteau, mais puis après ça, oui, mais alors arrivent les problèmes attentionnels.
Après ça, j'ai vu le bouquin là qui était là, mais j'ai été le ranger et puis j'ai été absorbé par mon téléphone.
Et puis j'ai oublié que le tram nonante-deux, il était stoppé pour l'instant. Et voilà. Et donc on arrive un quart d'heure en retard.
Oui, c'est ça. Donc une combinaison de plusieurs choses. Effectivement, voilà, faire plusieurs choses en même temps.
Par exemple, faire la cuisine en discutant avec quelqu'un, tout en faisant attention à autre chose, etc. Ça sature vite fait la mémoire de travail qui est, voilà, particulièrement difficile pour la personne concernée.
Il y a beaucoup de patients d'ailleurs qui vous disent qu'ils ne peuvent pas s'empêcher de faire plusieurs choses en même temps.
Il y a d'ailleurs des patients qui vont vous dire que pour pouvoir se concentrer... vous savez, c'est très marrant. Je reviens du congrès mondial du TDAH hier.
Et au congrès, j'ai été un jour assis à côté d'une dame qui tricotait. Donc c'est réservé aux professionnels de la santé.
Elle tricotait en écoutant les diverses conférences.
Et il y a beaucoup de patients qui disent : moi, pour travailler ou pour étudier ou pour faire la vaisselle, j'ai besoin qu'il y ait la télévision qui soit allumée, j'ai besoin d'écouter de la musique.
Et il y en a d'autres qui doivent travailler dans un silence absolument monacal.
Ouais. Et qu'est-ce qui explique ça, par exemple, ce besoin de tricoter pendant qu'on écoute une conférence ?
Il y a...
Pas spécifiquement pour cette dame, mais en général.
Je ne pense pas qu'il y ait des études scientifiques sur le sujet. Je pense que c'est un moyen de contrôler son hyperactivité mentale.
Si vous ne faites qu'écouter la conférence, votre monde intérieur va vous absorber et vous allez commencer en même temps à penser à : est-ce que j'ai fermé la porte de mon hôtel ?
Oh là, je ne dois pas oublier d'appeler quelqu'un en fin de conférence. Ou là là là là, mon Dieu, mais ça va être quoi encore la conférence suivante, alors qu'on est occupé à écouter la précédente.
Et donc, je pense que le fait de tricoter permet de quelque part diviser son attention entre le tricot et la conférence, mais pas entre la conférence et mille autres pensées.
C'est une façon de gérer son attention.
Oui, ça rejoint tout à fait ma propre expérience. Moi, je joue à Tetris plutôt que de tricoter, mais voilà. Ça serait gentil à faire.
Et inversement, voilà, il y a d'autres activités où ce n'est pas possible de faire plusieurs choses en même temps. Par exemple, on ne peut pas lire un livre et en même temps tricoter.
Alors, voilà, c'est difficile de lire un livre et de tricoter. C'est difficile quand on est une femme ou un homme politique de donner une conférence et de tricoter, même si fréquemment, ils tricotent, mais
verbalement ou mentalement, mais ça, c'est un autre problème.
Oui, oui. Ok. D'autres exemples avant qu'on passe à la suite, d'autres exemples de dysfonctions exécutives qu'on ne soupçonne pas forcément chez ces personnes-là.
Le monde de l'inhibition, c'est un monde passionnant. L'inhibition, c'est une des fonctions exécutives. L'inhibition, ça veut dire quoi ?
Ça veut dire s'empêcher de.
La vie avec soi et avec les autres, c'est en permanence s'empêcher de.
Et quand un patient écoute son épouse ou sa compagne, et qu'une compagne écoute son compagnon ou son mari ou sa compagne, son autre compagne, eh bien, il faut
inhiber son attention.
Inhiber son attention, ça veut dire que si j'écoute et qu'il y a un camion poubelle qui passe, je dois m'empêcher de tourner la tête, de regarder, de me dire : ah là là, aujourd'hui, il fait vraiment beaucoup de bruit, ce camion poubelle.
Je vais tout de même regarder pour voir ce qui se passe.
C'est très cliché, mais c'est vrai.
C'est très cliché, mais c'est vrai. Et le problème, en fait, c'est que le cerveau a beaucoup de mal à trier les informations qui viennent du monde environnant.
Et globalement, une alarme incendie, ça a la même valeur que le camion poubelle ou qu'un oiseau qui passe ou que n'importe quoi.
Ce qui est absolument passionnant, c'est qu'on sait aujourd'hui qu'on a tout autant de difficultés à inhiber notre attention qui est portée vers notre monde intérieur.
Parce que les fonctions exécutives, ça veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire les capacités à exécuter une tâche, n'importe quelle tâche, même un truc de loisir.
Et quand vous exécutez une tâche, toutes les pensées n'ont pas la même importance. Il y a des pensées qui sont fondamentales dans la tâche que vous êtes occupé à exécuter.
Mais si vous commencez à penser à plein d'autres choses,
Eh bien, vous allez avoir un problème de fonction exécutive. Donc les capacités d'inhibition, ces capacités, c'est la capacité à inhiber, à faire le tri dans ce qui se passe dans son environnement extérieur.
C'est la capacité à faire le tri dans ce qui se passe dans son environnement intérieur. Et c'est la capacité, après ça, à inhiber les comportements.
Alors, on liste ici donc une série de difficultés, de dysfonctions exécutives. On parle parfois également d'avantages, de forces, de choses que les personnes TDAH arrivent à faire mieux que d'autres.
Est-ce qu'il y a du vrai là-dedans ?
Oui, y a pas mal d'études scientifiques qui sont occupées à sortir maintenant. Vous allez me dire : « J'arrête pas de parler d'études scientifiques » parce que, in fine, mon avis personnel-
C'est ce que font les chercheurs, les chercheurs.
Voilà. Je suis un clinicien, mais mon avis personnel, je me dis toujours, n'a pas grande importance.
Ce qu'un clinicien doit faire, c'est absorber ce qui s'apprend.
Mh.
Oui, oui, oui, bien sûr, les TDA, comme tous les TDA le savent, ils ont plus de capacité à-- vous avez utilisé de l'anglais tout à l'heure, to think out of the box.
D'accord.
À avoir une pensée qui sort du cadre.
Mh.
Ils sont probablement plus créatifs. Certaines études semblent dire qu'ils seraient peut-être plus résilients.
À force, dans leur vie, d'avoir fait face à des difficultés multiples et nombreuses, il y a eu quelques études qui ont montré que,
avec l'âge venant, cet apprentissage dans l'adaptation de ces difficultés au monde extérieur ferait qu'ils seraient plus capables, plus tard, quand certaines difficultés physiques ou cognitives arrivent, à y faire face.
Peut-être un billet de sélection là-dedans, puisque à côté de ça, il y en a de nombreux qui galèrent vraiment, vraiment très fort.
Vous donniez l'exemple de la personne qui fixait son mouchoir pendant une demi-heure. Y a des personnes qui n'y arrivent pas et qui, du coup-
Vous m'avez demandé s'il y avait certains avantages.
Oui, oui, tout à fait.
Vous m'avez pas demandé s'il n'y avait que des avantages.
Non, non, ouais, parce que si on généralise l'idée que de manière générale, ils sont plus résilients, bon, ça dépend.
De manière générale, ils ne sont pas plus résilients. Certains pourraient être plus résilients en vieillissant.
C'est ça, voilà, c'est ça.
Mais à l'inverse, on démontre qu'y a plus de divorces, y a plus de solitude.
Ah oui, tout à fait.
Y a plus de solitude, y a des environnements sociaux plus restreints, moins d'amis.
Oui, oui.
Y a plus de conflits familiaux avec les enfants. Donc, oui.
Je vais revenir sur
l'autre exemple que vous avez donné qui est la prison, mais juste avant ça, au niveau des avantages,
quelque chose qui, moi, me vient, c'est le fait qu'une fois que je me suis lancé dans une tâche et je suis vraiment passionné par cette tâche,
il peut m'arriver de rester dessus pendant 14 heures chrono et de vraiment m'y donner à fond et de travailler dessus sans arrêt, là où peut-être que d'autres personnes iraient simplement dormir.
Le fait d'avoir la capacité à certains moments d'être hyperfocus-
C'est ça.
Est listé effectivement parmi les avantages. Sauf si on commence à être, comme c'est le cas pour certains patients, hyperfocus vers des choses qui nous éloignent de ce qu'on a véritablement ou besoin de faire.
Bah oui, oui, forcément.
Parce qu'être hyperfocus sur World of Warcraft, c'est très chouette pendant deux heures, mais si c'est douze heures par jour pendant deux semaines, ça pose problème.
Donc là, on touche à la notion d'addiction, finalement.
Voilà, exactement.
Puisque ces tâches-là sont beaucoup plus chargées en dopamine à court terme, voilà. Vis-à-vis donc de ce que vous disiez sur-- vous disiez que des patients, enfin, que ce n'était pas rare de trouver des personnes TDAH dans les prisons.
Pourquoi est-ce que vous dites ça ?
Moi, je le dis pas. Les études scientifiques le disent. Dans les-
Vous citez les études, ouais.
Non, je le dis à travers les études. Bah parce que dans les pays anglo-saxons et dans les pays du nord de l'Europe, y a eu des études très claires.
On a pris la peine d'aller dans les prisons, de faire passer des examens aux gens qui étaient volontaires, évidemment, et de diagnostiquer des TDA.
On estime qu'à peu près 30 % des personnes qui sont incarcérées souffrent d'un TDA. Alors, je n'ai pas dit qu'ils ne souffraient que d'un TDA-
Ouais.
Et qu'ils n'avaient pas d'autres problématiques associées. Mais voilà. Et y a des études en cours sur l'intérêt de traiter les patients TDA qui le désirent et qui ont des problèmes, justement, d'impulsivité, d'hyperactivité.
Donc ça, c'est une observation et on pourrait ensuite spéculer sur ce qui explique cette corrélation et ce qui fait qu'on observe un pourcentage significatif dans ces populations.
Oh, vous savez, ce qui l'explique, c'est extrêmement simple. Vous avez un TDA qui est un TDA important, avec une importante hyperactivité, avec une importante impulsivité.
C'est ça, ouais.
Vous allez avoir un accident de voiture avec peut-être femme et enfants à bord. Vous avez eu très, très peur. Vous avez une dysrégulation, un problème de régulation émotionnelle.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Vous allez faire comme d'habitude. Les émotions vont monter extrêmement rapidement, extrêmement intensément, beaucoup trop intensément.
Vous n'êtes plus capable de gérer votre attention sur votre femme, vos enfants, sur l'accident lui-même. Non, non. Tout est absorbé par les aspects émotionnels.
Vous sortez de la voiture, vous assommez le conducteur, on va dire adverse, même si je suis pas sûr qu'il soit adverse, qui-
L'ennemi.
Qui tombe par terre, qui fait une hémorragie cérébrale. Vous allez très probablement faire de la prison. Mais on peut être quelqu'un qui est extrêmement empathique, qui va aider
la vieille dame qui a du mal à traverser le passage piéton, à l'aider à traverser et être quelqu'un d'extrêmement impulsif.
C'est ça. L'impulsivité est un vecteur important.
Et ne pas pouvoir gérer ses-
Oui, oui.
Ses réactions.
Et peut-être également, donc, puisqu'on parlait de la tendance à l'addiction, donc les substances, les choses comme ça.
On estime qu'une trente--
Alors, les addictions, les addictions, y a des addictions à tout, hein. Y a les addictions à l'alcool, addictions au cannabis, addictions à d'autres drogues, addictions à la cigarette,
addictions-- Alors, certaines sont beaucoup plus
psychiques que physiques, d'autres sont plus physiques que psychiques.
Addictions aux écrans, addictions à plein de choses. Oui, les problèmes d'addiction sont cinq, six, sept fois plus fréquents-
Oui.
En cas de TDAH.
Oui, oui. On a beaucoup parlé de la dopamine. Vous avez fait le lien donc également avec les troubles anxieux, le fait de se sentir vraiment dans des états de panique parfois,
et que ce sont souvent les mêmes personnes.
Y a donc à ce moment-là un autre neurotransmetteur dont on parle aussi parfois en connexion avec le TDAH, qui est donc la norépinéphrine ou noradrénaline.
Noradrénaline, oui.
Quel est son rôle dans le TDAH ?
Il est probablement relativement parallèle à celui de la dopamine, sauf qu'il est beaucoup moins connu, beaucoup moins étudié, parce que pour des raisons techniques,
notamment en imagerie, en imagerie cérébrale fonctionnelle, etc., il est, c'est-- voilà, il est beaucoup plus compliqué à traquer.
Et à provoquer aussi peut-être. Donc pour rappeler ce que c'est une norépinéphrine.
C'est aussi un neurotransmetteur qui, par ailleurs, est aussi probablement déficitaire. Et il y a certains traitements
non psychostimulants, c'est-à-dire des traitements qu'on appelle de deuxième ligne, qui agissent également sur la noradrénaline, qui ont une double action sur la dopamine et sur la noradrénaline.
Donc pour rappeler, donc, c'est le neurotransmetteur qu'on observe dans les situations de fight or flight, par exemple, de panique, quoi.
Il y a plein de choses, y compris d'un point de vue hormonal, cortisol, etc. Et effectivement, noradrénaline, adrénaline, noradrénaline, qui sont sursecrétées en cas de situation de danger.
Et on peut repartir sur un débat de Septante Minutes sur le fait que ce n'est pas par hasard que cinquante pour cent des patients adultes qui ont un TDA ont également un trouble anxieux.
C'est ça.
Parce qu'ils ont probablement-
Une dysrégulation.
Une dysrégulation de tous-- cette cascade, cette fois-ci hormonale et neurotransmetteur, liée aux problèmes de stress.
Oui. Alors, on va faire le lien donc avec la notion de motivation, puisqu'on a parlé donc cette cécité dans le temps, des objectifs qui sont lointains et sur lesquels on n'a pas forcément envie de se concentrer quand on a un TDAH.
On entend parfois cette notion de moteurs, de ce qui va motiver, ce qui va permettre d'avancer une personne qui a un TDAH.
Et on va parler à ce moment-là de notions comme l'urgence. L'urgence va permettre de passer à l'action. La passion va permettre de passer à l'action.
L'intérêt, la novelty, la nouveauté, quelque chose d'original qu'on ne connaît pas encore. Parfois, le challenge, le fait d'être mis au défi va permettre de passer à l'action.
Du coup, est-ce que ça fait-
Beaucoup de drivers, je m'excuse de vous interrompre, beaucoup de drivers différents dans ce que vous venez de citer.
Tout à fait, oui.
Et qui ont des fonctions différentes.
Voilà. Mais donc, si on fait la comparaison avec une personne neurotypique, cette personne-là va savoir à ce moment-là
trier sa priorité en fonction simplement de l'importance plutôt que de façon aussi impulsive que ce qui m'intéresse, ce qui me passionne, ce qui est urgent.
Alors, ce n'est pas parce qu'on est neurotypique qu'on est parfait hein.
Oui, non, bien sûr.
Donc, y a plein de neurotypiques qui dysfonctionnent, mais ils n'ont pas besoin de ces triggers.
Hein.
Le trigger de la passion, ben oui, parce que la passion va très probablement vous rendre hyperfocus et que là, vous n'aurez absolument plus besoin d'autres choses et vous serez dedans.
L'urgence, si maintenant, je ne rends pas ma déclaration fiscale, si maintenant, je ne paye pas mes factures ou si maintenant, je ne termine pas mon devoir pour l'unif ou l'école, ben c'est foutu ou c'est grave.
Ça va effectivement, à ce moment-là, déclencher toute une cascade qui est la cascade du stress. Ça va très probablement permettre de désactiver des réseaux cérébraux qui sont les réseaux cérébraux impliqués dans le vagabondage de la pensée.
Ça va permettre de mieux activer les réseaux liés aux fonctions exécutives et ça va permettre de travailler.
Pour certains patients, c'est totalement l'inverse. Pour certains patients très anxieux, la montée de l'anxiété va les paralyser complètement.
Ils seront plus capables de faire quoi que ce soit.
Finalement, ça peut être les deux. On attend l'urgence pour pouvoir s'y mettre et puis finalement, on est paralysé par l'urgence.
Tout est possible.
Voilà.
Et donc l'urgence peut avoir un effet vraiment de booster chez certains patients et ça peut avoir un effet complètement paralysant chez d'autres.
Oui. Et il peut aussi y avoir donc une, comment dire, une hyposensibilité à l'urgence, c'est-à-dire qu'on va finalement dire : « Non, mais j'ai besoin d'encore plus d'urgence.
J'ai besoin de m'y mettre cinq minutes avant plutôt que la veille. »
Vous parlez de ce qu'on appelle les mécanismes de compensation.
Oui, voilà, c'est ça.
Donc les patients, tous les patients, vous savez, beaucoup de patients TDAH me disent : « Mais finalement, qu'est-ce que je pourrais faire pour m'améliorer ?
» Alors évidemment, il y a des trucs et astuces et bien entendu, il y a des formations, notamment de groupes en prise en charge de type comportemental qui permettent de donner,
d'améliorer son environnement, d'améliorer sa façon d'aborder les choses, de se donner plus de chances
d'arriver à ses objectifs.
Mais la majorité des patients, vous savez, ils sont déjà là avec leurs alertes et leurs alarmes sur leur GSM ou leur Post-it ou leur système de délégation,
alors s'ils ont la chance d'avoir une secrétaire, à leur secrétaire ou à leur compagne, compagnon, de choses qu'ils ont beaucoup de mal à faire eux-mêmes,
à leur conseiller fiscal, s'il est bon.
Vous parliez un peu plus tôt donc de cette difficulté très récurrente à faire la vaisselle pour les personnes TDAH parce que voilà, c'est pas forcément le plus récompensant, le plus intéressant.
Voilà, on donnait la notion de contrainte, mais je dois confesser que recevoir des gens dans mon salon pour faire ce podcast est une très bonne motivation pour faire la vaisselle.
Et puis sérieusement, donc vis-à-vis des molécules qu'on propose dans le cadre de traitements médicamenteux, les molécules qu'on propose donc aux patients,
la plus commune aujourd'hui, c'est le méthylphénidate-
Oui.
Le fameux Ritaline ou Rilatine en Belgique. L'anecdote est assez drôle. Qu'est-ce que ça provoque donc dans le cerveau d'un patient TDAH, cette molécule ?
Ah peut-être pour commencer sur l'aspect qui est extrêmement-- qui fait vraiment débat dans les médias et y compris dans les médias de santé, sur les traitements du TDA.
J'ai finalement-- beaucoup de patients viennent et beaucoup de gens, je pense, qui s'intéressent au TDA, qui sont pas des professionnels de la santé, ont des avis très tranchés, très extrêmes sur la question.
Les uns, c'est : les traitements médicamenteux comme le méthylphénidate, ce sont des drogues inventées par l'industrie pharmaceutique pour un trouble inventé par l'industrie pharmaceutique pour gagner des millions de dollars.
On s'approche du complotisme, à ce moment-là. On est en plein dedans.
On est-- Mais comme vous le savez, c'est très à la mode.
Oui, oui.
Et à l'inverse, y a des gens qui disent : « Ah docteur, vite, vite, je voudrais enfin un traitement parce qu'avec ça, ma vie va être merveilleuse et ça va être miraculeux.
» C'est ni l'un ni l'autre. J'adore récupérer cette métaphore qui a été utilisée notamment pour le titre de livre sur le TDAH chez l'enfant par une de mes consœurs.
Les traitements du TDAH, ce sont des lunettes. Ce sont des lunettes mentales. Vous savez, en médecine, y a des médicaments que quand vous les absorbez, vous avez rien à faire.
Si vous avez une infection pulmonaire, urinaire, quoi que ce soit, et que c'est une infection microbienne avec bactéries, vous allez peut-être devoir prendre des antibiotiques.
Et si l'infection est sévère, vous allez être hospitalisé. Et tout ce qu'on va vous demander de faire, c'est éventuellement de regarder quelques émissions débiles à la télévision.
Donc, vous avez rien à faire. Vous prenez votre traitement ou on vous l'injecte par voie intraveineuse et ça passe.
Mh.
Mais le traitement du TDA, c'est juste l'inverse. Le traitement du TDA, y compris médicamenteux, c'est un outil. Si vous êtes extrêmement myope, c'est toujours la même métaphore que je donne à mes patients pour expliquer les traitements du TDA.
Si vous êtes très très myope,
que vous voyez pas les paysages en vous promenant ou en partant en vacances, que vous n'arrivez à rien lire sauf à mettre votre nez sur l'écran
d'un ordinateur,
que vous ne reconnaissez pas les visages des gens quand vous vous promenez en rue et que vous vous faites écraser une fois sur deux par un scooter
ou un vélo quand vous traversez la rue parce que vous le voyez pas venir, je vais vous prescrire des lunettes.
Mh.
Et grâce à ça, vous allez voir le paysage, vous allez pouvoir plus facilement peut-être lire et assurer votre sécurité, etc., etc.
Mais ça ne supprimera pas la myopie, quoi, c'est un outil.
Un, ça ne supprime pas la myopie. Et deux, surtout, les lunettes ne vont pas vous faire étudier, ne vont pas vous faire voyager, ne vont pas vous faire socialiser.
Donc cette notion de difficulté avec la motivation, avec l'urgence, etc., ça reste là.
Les lunettes vont vous permettre de.
Oui.
Le traitement du TDA est un traitement qui va vous permettre d'améliorer vos difficultés attentionnelles, probablement aussi votre impulsivité, votre hyperactivité et très probablement aussi l'hyperactivité mentale.
Il va vous permettre d'aller vers là où vous avez envie d'aller. Ça ne fait pas aimer les choux de Bruxelles à quelqu'un qui n'aime pas les choux de Bruxelles.
Mh. Ça ne transforme pas la personne, ça lui donne un petit coup de pouce.
Ça ne transforme certainement pas la personne, ni dans sa personnalité, ni dans ce qu'il aime ou qu'il n'aime pas. Et
il se reconnaîtra peut-être, mais je me rappellerai toujours d'un étudiant qui voulait absolument... Enfin, les parents amènent un étudiant de plus de 18 ans parce qu'il voulait faire des études, je vais pas les citer,
pour pas qu'il puisse être identifié.
Des études universitaires très très complexes, dans un domaine très complexe pour lequel il était effectivement très doué depuis qu'il est très jeune.
Et puis, les parents suspectent un TDA parce qu'il en est à sa quatrième session de deuxième année. Il va être exclu de l'université.
Il essaye d'avoir un recours. On pose la question : est-ce qu'il a un TDA ? Quelques consultations se passent. Effectivement, il a un TDA et un traitement est débuté.
Et quel est le résultat du traitement ? Nul. La catastrophe, il rate tout. Et un jour, on s'était vu suffisamment de fois, il me faisait confiance.
Il me dit : « Mais en fait, moi, je veux pas faire ça. Je veux être artiste. »
Ah oui, d'accord. Une belle histoire. Oui, ça, ça résume bien le truc.
Et aujourd'hui, il prend son traitement, mais pas dans le même cadre.
C'est ça.
Et ça l'aide beaucoup.
Oui, oui. À l'inverse, j'ai quelques exemples de personnes qui
commencent à prendre ce traitement et qui remarquent que effectivement, ils ont l'esprit beaucoup moins dispersé, beaucoup plus focalisé, les idées beaucoup plus calmes qu'auparavant, un apaisement de la pensée
et qui se disent : « Mais je ne me reconnais plus.
J'ai l'impression que ma... » Parce que peut-être ces personnes-là se définissaient largement par ces aspects-là du TDAH.
Et tout d'un coup, se disaient : « Mais je ne me reconnais plus. Je n'ai plus l'impression d'être moi. »
Alors,
un : oui, les traitements du TDAH sont extrêmement efficaces. Deux.
Ce phénomène-là, alors moi, chez les adultes, pour peu que vous passiez suffisamment de temps à expliquer ce qu'est le TDA,
quels sont les effets du traitement, quels sont les effets secondaires du traitement, qu'est-ce qu'on peut en attendre, qu'est-ce qu'on peut ne pas en attendre.
Ce genre de retours, je les ai rarement, mais c'est par exemple quelque chose qui est plus fréquemment décrit chez les ados.
Mh.
Parce que l'impulsivité, parfois une certaine rapidité à faire des associations de pensées font que certains ados, et on connaît des stand-uppers qui
sont très très bons là-dedans et qui ont un TDA,
ben certains ados sont particulièrement marrants et comme ils sont hyperactifs et impulsifs, eh bien, ce sont les grands rigolos de la classe, ils font se marrer tout le monde, ils sortent des vannes,
parfois, c'est pas tout à fait adapté, ça peut être dur, humiliant, etc.
Mais ça fait rire tout le monde. Et effectivement, comme vous le disiez, on contient mieux ses pensées, on arrive à mieux sélectionner ses pensées, on réduit ses difficultés attentionnelles.
Et... ben oui, certains ados disent : « Ah ben oui, je me concentre mieux sur ce que je fais, y compris lire, y compris travailler pour l'école, y compris discuter avec des amis, mais je suis moins marrant ».
Mh.
Voilà. Chez les adultes, c'est tout de même très très très très peu fréquent.
Oui. Donc ça, c'est pour le méthylphénidate qui est le standard, hein, la Ritaline. Donc on peut-- alors, vous connaissez certainement l'anecdote mieux que moi, mais donc il me semble que le nom Ritaline
vient du fait que la personne qui l'a découvert l'a nommé après son épouse, sa compagne, Rita.
Sa compagne s'appelait Rita et manifestement jouait mieux au tennis.
Et puis quand c'est arrivé en Belgique...
Ça a posé problème.
Voilà, un truc de copyright quelque part.
Exactement.
Il a fallu un S et deux syllabes.
Et donc nous sommes le seul pays au monde, à ma connaissance-
Rilatine, c'est ça
...où quand nous avons des patients qui viennent d'autres pays, ils nous disent : « Est-ce que vous pourriez me prescrire de la Ritaline ? »
C'est ça.
Et je leur dis : « Ah, ça, ce ne sera pas possible ».
Ah ah. Oui, oui.
N'oublions pas que Ritaline, Rilatine, c'est un nom commercial.
C'est ça.
Que la molécule est le méthylphénidate et que pour ne pas qu'il y ait de publicité, parce qu'il n'y a pas de raison qu'il y en ait, il existe de multiples autres formes, le Concerta, le Métylinette, l'Équasim,
la Rilatine et les formes génériques qui, si elles contiennent toutes du méthylphénidate, ont des distributions dans le sang et dans le cerveau différentes et elles ne s'équivalent pas.
Ce qui convient à l'un ne convient pas obligatoirement à l'autre.
Il y a des dosages différents, il y a des formules retard qui durent toute la journée, qui peuvent durer quatre heures.
Voilà, des formules de retard qui sont d'ailleurs différentes d'un médicament à l'autre.
Mh. Alors ensuite, il y a ce que je vais appeler vulgairement le cousin de la méthylphénidate, qui sont ce qui était pendant longtemps le standard.
Et voilà, il me semble qu'aux États-Unis, on en parle encore beaucoup, ce sont les amphétamines.
Et ça l'est toujours.
Oui.
Donc globalement, dans la majorité des pays, y compris la majorité des pays européens, si je parle pour les adultes hein, mais je ne m'avance pas chez les enfants.
Il y a, globalement, on peut estimer qu'il y a deux premières lignes, le méthylphénidate et la lisdexamfétamine
qui va se transformer en amphétamine une fois avalée et qui sont tous les deux considérés comme des premières lignes, c'est-à-dire des traitements
de très grande qualité.
La lisdexamfétamine étant probablement un peu plus efficace.
Mh.
Oui. Et donc, ce sont alors des molécules qu'on range dans la famille un petit peu des excitants. C'est-- en fait, c'est-
Des psychostimulants.
C'est du speed.
Bien entendu.
Voilà. Et c'est pour ça que c'est parfois malheureusement un petit peu détourné et que ces substances sont très surveillées.
Un, ce sont des psychostimulants qui n'ont rien d'un excitant.
Mh.
Parce que par définition, l'effet qu'ils font chez les patients TDA, c'est l'inverse de l'excitation.
Voilà. Mais chez un patient qui ne l'est pas-
Ils leur permettent de se réguler.
C'est ce qu'on reproche à tort chez les enfants. Quand on connaît très mal le TDA et toutes les bêtises qu'on entend, on dit : « Ah oui,
on va lui prescrire de la Rilatine parce qu'évidemment, comme il emmerde tout le monde, on va le calmer, on va le maquer et comme ça, il dormira bien sur sa chaise ».
Ça ne fait pas dormir.
Mh.
La première chose, ça permet de se réguler. Ça ne permet pas de se calmer et ça n'excite pas. Et les premiers à être très heureux de pouvoir se réguler, de réguler leurs pensées, de réguler leur impulsivité, de réguler leurs pensées,
ce sont les patients eux-mêmes, y compris les plus jeunes.
Quand on leur explique, qu'on prend suffisamment de temps pour leur expliquer que c'est pas un truc pour les emmerder, que papa et maman vont leur imposer, mais que c'est pour eux, pour les aider.
Et alors, avant de passer à la suite, très rapidement citer donc une troisième molécule qui est l'atomoxétine, qui est, voilà, par exemple, pas disponible en Belgique parce que pas remboursée, parce que très chère.
De nouveau disponible en Belgique, mais à des prix de-
Oui, voilà
...pas défiant toute concurrence dans le sens positif du terme, mais négatif du terme.
C'est comme cent vingt euros la boîte alors que-
C'est une vraie molécule qui a vraiment sa place en deuxième ligne, c'est-à-dire quand il y a des problèmes avec le-- ou une,
une impossibilité à administrer des traitements de première ligne, mais aucun traitement n'est remboursé en Belgique, celui-là non plus, et on est très largement au-dessus de cent euros aujourd'hui.
C'est ça. Donc c'est quelque chose comme cent vingt euros pour une boîte. Là-haut, aux Pays-Bas, ce sera autour de trente euros parce que c'est beaucoup plus remboursé.
Voilà. Je le sais puisque c'est ça que j'étais prescrit. Euh...
Je vous le confirme.
Donc ça, c'est-- on a un petit peu fait le tour du paysage.
Il y en a encore d'autres hein, il y en a encore d'autres, mais voilà, qui sont utilisés beaucoup plus-
Seconde, troisième ligne, voilà
...qui sont beaucoup utilisés plus rarement.
Oui, oui, voilà. Alors, on s'approche tout doucement donc de la fin de cet entretien. Voilà, je vais revenir sur un exemple qui était tout particulièrement pertinent.
C'est quand on parlait de cette difficulté pour, par exemple, les étudiants qui voulaient faire-- finir leur bachelier, finir leur master, mais qui avaient cette paralysie.
Je ne pense pas à l'exemple de l'artiste que vous donniez, mais les étudiants qui aimeraient vraiment arriver au bout de leurs études, mais qui n'y arrivent pas.
Effectivement, là, on va faire face inévitablement à un jugement très important, une incompréhension très importante de la part de la population, une grande
culpabilisation, une grande stigmatisation en disant effectivement que ces gens-là sont des paresseux, n'en font pas assez, etc.
Comment est-ce qu'on résout ces questions ? Est-ce qu'il y a un manque de conscientisation autour de ces questions ?
On va subir un jugement extrêmement important quand on ne paye pas ses factures, quand on
roule trop vite parce qu'on est impulsif, parce qu'on change de boulot tous les deux ans, parce qu'on s'ennuie extrêmement vite, parce qu'on a tendance à crier dans des moments où on devrait pas le faire.
Ça, vous savez, c'est toute la grande difficulté entre un diagnostic de trouble et la responsabilité personnelle. Où est-ce que s'arrête l'un, où est-ce que commence l'autre ?
Moi, je tiens un discours dans lequel je dis à la fois, je pense qu'avoir un diagnostic de TDA, ça permet pour beaucoup de gens de se déculpabiliser par rapport à plein de choses qu'ils ont vécues.
Je parle de nouveau d'adultes, parce que je m'occupe que d'adultes,
qu'ils ont vécues plus jeunes et de difficultés qu'ils ont rencontrées, que ce soit leur capacité à s'organiser, à écouter, à ranger leur chambre, ce pour quoi ils se sont fait engueuler mille et une fois.
Et le fait qu'à partir du moment où ils ont fait la démarche diagnostique, où il y a des traitements qui débutent, médicamenteux, non médicamenteux, ben là, ça devient notre responsabilité partagée entre eux et les spécialistes de santé
de tout faire pour que les choses évoluent.
Évoluent pas selon les normes de la société, mais évoluent vers là où eux ont envie d'aller dans l'amélioration de
leurs capacités exécutives, pas rien que pour travailler, mais pour apprendre un instrument de musique, pour lire un roman, pour regarder un film de A à Z sans se lever, sans regarder son GSM, sans aller faire pipi deux fois et ouvrir la fenêtre.
Et donc c'est notre rôle à chacun et ça devient à ce moment-là quelque chose qui est magnifique, qui est vraiment quelque chose de partagé entre le patient et le thérapeute, le médecin, enfin le spécialiste de santé.
Ouais. Au niveau sociétal, est-ce que... En tout cas, la question, la réponse est presque dans la question.
J'ai l'impression qu'aujourd'hui,
il y a peut-être une amélioration. C'est vrai, en particulier ces dix, douze dernières années, mais malgré tout, de manière générale, il reste une incompréhension,
une mauvaise compréhension de ce trouble par la population générale et on reste dans un,
un jugement de valeur assez important.
Est-ce qu'il ne serait pas intéressant que, par exemple, les enseignants en maternelle, en primaire, etc.,
soient formés vis-à-vis de ces enjeux pour que, ben, plutôt que de les faire culpabiliser, puissent pointer, orienter les parents vers un diagnostic ?
Alors, certainement en maternelle et en primaire, de nouveau, mais oui, à cent pour cent, je vais laisser la réponse à mes collègues neuropédiatres ou pédiatriques.
Mais même chez les adultes, il y a une grande méconnaissance dans le monde de la santé. Aujourd'hui, dans les guidelines australiens, on insiste sur le fait qu'il faut qu'il y ait des red flags, c'est-à-dire que
quelqu'un qui consomme trop d'alcool, quelqu'un qui consomme trop de cannabis,
quelqu'un qui a des problèmes d'accidentologie, des accidents répétés, quelqu'un qui est incarcéré, quelqu'un...
Bref, il y a des--
sûrement dix, quinze, vingt situations typiques
dans lesquelles, y compris les professionnels de santé, les médecins traitants, les neurologues, les psychiatres, les addictologues, évidemment, devraient se dire : « Ouh, est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas un TDA ?
» Le traitement du TDA ne va pas être un traitement miracle qui va tout résoudre, mais-
C'est une grille de lecture.
Un, c'est une grille de lecture, mais on parlait de l'efficacité des traitements du TDA et je me permets de vous prendre trente secondes.
Dites-moi.
Bien sûr, on l'étudie sur les capacités attentionnelles, les capacités à gérer son impulsivité, son hyperactivité. Mais on voit surtout l'impact extraordinaire à long terme sur la vie.
Le fait de donner précocement dans l'enfance et l'adolescence à des patients TDA un traitement médicamenteux, ça va réduire de manière extrêmement marquée le risque d'addiction à l'alcool, aux drogues.
Ça va réduire le risque d'accident, ça va réduire la mortalité, ça va réduire les hospitalisations, quelles que soient les causes, y compris les hospitalisations pour fractures, pour accidents, etc.
Ça va réduire le risque de suicide.
Oui, absolument.
Qui est augmenté dans le TDA.
En particulier donc dans les cas de stigmatisation, culpabilisation où effectivement, on finit par s'identifier comme étant un bon à rien.
Exactement. Mais donc traiter le TDA, c'est bien entendu traiter les fonctions attentionnelles, etc. Mais c'est modifier le parcours de vie des patients.
Oui. On est dans une société où on valorise très fort, on a cette notion de réussir par son effort, on travaille dur et on est récompensé pour ça.
C'est forcément un modèle de société qui est très compliqué pour les personnes qui, comme on le disait, ont des dysfonctions exécutives, ont tendance à procrastiner, ont des problèmes de motivation, etc.
Dans quelle mesure est-ce qu'on est en possibilité-- est-ce qu'il existe des moyens de fournir aux personnes concernées un autre paradigme, une autre façon d'aborder la vie ?
Je vais vous contredire.
Dites-moi.
Si je peux me permettre.
Dites-moi, allez-y.
C'est un des premiers trucs que j'explique aux patients qui ont un TDA, qui pour la grande majorité se considèrent au mieux comme fainéants.
Oui.
L'immense majorité, 99 % des patients TDA,
sont tout sauf des fainéants. Ce sont des gens qui travaillent énormément, pas toujours avec efficacité, pas toujours avec les résultats qu'ils désirent obtenir, mais généralement, ce sont des gens qui font énormément de choses.
Alors, ils estiment toujours qu'ils en font pas assez, qu'ils sont pas assez bons, qu'ils devraient faire mieux, hein, on revient à l'internalisation précoce de jugement de valeur.
Mais donc, ce n'est pas qu'il faut changer de paradigme sur le fait qu'il faut faire moins, parce que bien sûr, ils devraient... c'est pas que la société devrait amener les gens à faire moins.
Ce sont les patients TDA qui, dans la grande majorité, font beaucoup plus que la majorité de la population.
D'accord.
Eux devraient faire moins pour revenir probablement à la norme. Alors, ils font pas toujours... il y en a qui font avec énormément de réussite.
On étudie maintenant tout ce groupe de TDA qui sont des entrepreneurs, des gens qui travaillent dans l'HORECA, qui ont quatre restos, qui ont des postes de très haut niveau.
Mais même, tous les patients TDA, quel que soit leur métier, manuel, intellectuel, leur difficulté parfois à maintenir un métier, ce sont des gros bouloteurs, ce sont des gros travailleurs.
Le paradigme qu'il faut changer, c'est le paradigme de : je dois toujours faire plus.
Je dois toujours me donner au max.
Et je dois toujours faire mieux.
Et je suis dans une espèce de système, en fait, qui est un système pervers qui n'a pas de fin.
Parce que quand vous avez un problème d'image de vous-même, le problème n'est pas que vous arriviez in fine, comme on le dit toujours : « Oh docteur, je voudrais tellement arriver à faire A, B ou C ».
Le jour où vous arriverez à faire A, B ou C, votre monde interne vous dira : « Il faut faire encore plus et encore mieux », parce que c'est toujours pas bon.
C'est pour ça que les traitements médicamenteux,
ils doivent être prescrits dans un contexte
et dans un contexte de ce qu'on appelle la psychoéducation,
c'est-à-dire comprendre ce qu'est le TDA, comprendre ce qu'est son TDA, comprendre l'implication que ça va avoir dans sa vie et comprendre la raison pour laquelle on va prendre son traitement.
Oui, oui. Encore une fois, cette grille de lecture qui donc va être amenée par, voilà, des neurologues, des psychiatres tels que vous, pour permettre aux patients de mieux se comprendre, voilà.
Malheureusement, et c'est là-dessus que j'aimerais vous amener, en Belgique, c'est pas ouf, hein, au niveau du marché, au niveau de la disponibilité des médecins pour avoir un diagnostic, pour être accompagné à ce niveau-là.
Qu'est-ce qui explique ça ?
Ah ben, en Belgique, c'est pas ouf pour plein de choses. C'est ouf pour plein de trucs. J'adore la Belgique, mais pas pour le TDA.
Clairement pas pour le TDA. Ben, déjà parce que les traitements ne sont pas remboursés, au-delà de 18 ans. Donc, 18 ans, pile, vous avez plus de remboursement.
C'est un des seuls pays européens,
alors qu'on nous raconte pas que ce sont pour des questions budgétaires, je vais pas les citer, mais il y a plein de pays qui ont des PIB bien inférieurs au nôtre, dans lesquels les traitements sont remboursés chez l'adulte.
Donc ça, c'est vraiment une notion politique, budgétaire de la-
Certaines notes internes de l'INAMI,
indiquent que le TDA chez l'adulte n'a pas été démontré et que les traitements n'ont pas prouvé leur efficacité, malgré un avis de 2021 du Conseil supérieur de la santé, qui dépend pourtant du SPF Santé,
qui était totalement favorable au traitement.
Mais manifestement, il y a des problèmes de communication. Donc ça, c'est la première chose qui est, j'ose le dire, terrifiante.
Ça veut dire que vous avez un premier tri de patients qui se fait simplement sur la capacité à payer. Alors, les seuls traitements
qui ne coûtent pas cher, ce sont certaines formes rapides de méthylphénidate, qui, pour des raisons X, Y, Q, Z, ne sont pas les plus prescrites.
Toutes les formes à durée d'action prolongée sont coûteuses à très coûteuses.
Voilà.
Voilà. Donc ça, c'est-
Ça, c'est terrible
...effectivement, ce premier aspect qui est le remboursement. Oui, c'est terrible, en effet. Le remboursement, donc, des médicaments pour les personnes qui en ont besoin, personnes adultes.
Adultes.
Et ensuite, un autre niveau qui est la formation des médecins. Vous avez parlé donc d'une formation, d'années de recherche très spécifiques dans un domaine très précis qui vous ont amené sur le TDA.
Mais y a pas énormément de médecins, pas énormément de psychologues qui sont sensibilisés à la question du TDA.
Alors, je pense qu'il y a beaucoup plus de psychologues que de médecins, si ce n'est que les psychologues peuvent assurer les prises en charge non médicamenteuses, mais ce ne sont pas des médecins, ils n'ont pas le droit de prescription.
Ils n'ont pas d'ailleurs le droit de diagnostic du TDA.
Aujourd'hui, c'est dans le cursus des psychologues, la reconnaissance du-
Ce n'est absolument pas dans le cursus des psychologues. Nos universités francophones... J'en témoigne puisque j'ai des étudiants en psycho à ma consultation.
Dans certaines universités que je ne citerai pas, certains professeurs que je ne citerai pas, tiennent toujours le discours que le TDAH est une invention.
Ah oui, d'accord.
Que le TDAH n'est que le symptôme de
dysfonctions, dysfonctionnements personnels, familiaux, sociétaux, etc.
Je ne dis pas qu'il n'y a pas d'influence de l'environnement sur l'expression du TDAH, donc qu'on ne me fasse pas passer non plus pour un extrémiste de la pharmacologie, ce qui n'est pas du tout mon cas.
Mais aujourd'hui, dire que le TDAH n'existe pas, enfin oui, la Terre est plate, tout le monde le sait.
Donc vous constatez un problème donc au niveau de la formation des psychologues, il me semble.
Des psychologues, en tout cas dans certaines universités, certainement, mais beaucoup au-delà de leur master s'intéressent au TDAH, des neuropsychologues, des cliniciens.
Dans la formation continue, alors.
Dans la formation continue et c'est vraiment très chouette à voir. Et chez les médecins,
alors, je ne vais pas jeter la pierre du tout aux médecins généralistes parce que je vous assure que je trouve que c'est déjà très compliqué de connaître un domaine de niche.
Le métier aujourd'hui de médecin généraliste, c'est un métier extrêmement difficile. Ce sont des gens qui doivent avoir une vision globale sur tout et je trouve qu'il n'y a pas de frein chez les médecins généralistes.
Beaucoup de médecins généralistes sont très à l'écoute, très attentifs, à la problématique du TDAH chez l'adulte et donc bravo à eux.
On ne forme pas assez de neurologues et de psychiatres au TDAH, mais on ne peut pas forcer les formations.
Il y a des choses qui sont occupées à changer. Et le professeur Pierre Ozsvalek, que vous avez interviewé dans un autre cadre, aujourd'hui est chef de service de, euh-
Erasme.
Du service de psychiatrie à l'hôpital Erasme, service adulte. Il va évidemment faire changer les choses, en tout cas, à l'ULB.
Oui, il donne des conférences. Oui, il est très motivé là-dessus.
Oui, et on est, là où je travaille, plusieurs à s'occuper du TDA, mais le problème, c'est même en amont de la formation des neurologues et des psychiatres, il y a un manque d'intérêt, mais qui est très régional.
Si vous regardez les statistiques de prescription du méthylphénidate, chez les enfants, parce que moi, je les ai pas, j'essaie de les avoir, mais je les ai pas chez les adultes.
Alors, elles datent d'il y a quelques années, mais globalement, il y a quelques années, on prescrivait trois à quatre fois plus de méthylphénidate en Flandre qu'à Bruxelles et en Wallonie.
Je pense que le monde médical flamand est beaucoup plus proche du monde anglo-saxon-
Voilà, j'allais le dire.
Avec plus d'intérêt pour des problématiques comme celles du TDA, avec des visions probablement plus scientifiques, si je peux me permettre.
Oui, et aussi, je crois, plus reconnaissante de la notion de diversité.
Et peut-être plus reconnaissante de la notion de diversité.
La notion de neurodiversité, finalement, est plus compatible, je pense, avec les philosophies anglo-saxonnes qu'avec l'universalisme français, par exemple.
C'est possible. C'est possible.
Bon, là, je spécule complètement, mais, euh...
Spéculons.
Nous sommes là pour ça. Oui, donc en effet, oui, je vous rejoins tout à fait. Il est vraiment pas rare que quand je rencontre une personne... alors,
encore une fois, j'ai la conviction que la plupart des personnes neurodivergentes du côté francophone, la grande majorité, ne savent pas qu'elles sont autistes ou TDA, etc.
Elles s'ignorent complètement.
C'est clair.
Voilà, elles ont pas forcément été sensibilisées à ça. Elles ont pas forcément eu besoin d'obtenir un diagnostic dans l'urgence.
Inversement, quand je les rencontre du côté flamand, souvent, elles sont tout à fait au courant, elles s'assument, elles se reconnaissent en tant que personnes neurodivergentes. Bon, peut-être pas-
C'est une expérience que moi, j'ai pas, mais donc...
Voilà, le ratio n'est pas inversé, mais en tout cas, voilà, je constate que c'est déjà un peu plus réparti.
En tout cas, le ratio en termes de traitement, c'était quatre pour un. Et effectivement, il y a plus de disponibilité de médecins du côté néerlandophone que du côté francophone.
Mais donc des difficultés au niveau des remboursements des médicaments, des difficultés au niveau de la formation des médecins et voilà, des psychologues, en tout cas du côté universitaire.
Donc, on a compris que, voilà, la Belgique n'était pas le meilleur lieu pour avoir un TDAH bien pris en charge.
Ce n'est pas le royaume du TDAH.
Voilà, c'est ça.
Chez l'adulte.
Et pour prendre votre exemple très concret, donc, vous n'acceptez pas de nouveaux patients, ce n'est pas la peine d'essayer de vous joindre pour obtenir un rendez-vous puisque c'est très compliqué.
Et chez vos collègues, c'est égal, on parle de listes d'attente de cinq, six ans, c'est très-
Il y a des listes d'attente de deux, trois ans, en tout cas chez ceux que je connais le mieux. Et je pense qu'il y a des... j'ai
eu des discussions avec l'un ou l'autre m'apprenant avec plaisir qu'il y avait de jeunes collègues en formation qui, en hôpital universitaire, se formaient.
Et un collègue neurologue avec qui j'ai discuté très récemment, qui m'a dit que lui aussi, il avait entamé une formation complémentaire sur le TDAH.
Donc, j'espère que ça va changer parce que je trouve que c'est terrifiant de dire à un patient qu'on ne peut pas le recevoir ou qu'il faut attendre trois ans pour avoir un rendez-vous.
Très bien. Mais donc voilà, on va peut-être vers le mieux. Pour l'instant, c'est pas terrible, mais euh... Alors, on va toucher à autre chose qui est que
aujourd'hui, donc cette sensibilisation aux enjeux de neurodiversité, aux enjeux de déficit de l'attention
ne se fait pas vraiment dans l'enseignement général, dans la population au sens large, mais se fait largement aujourd'hui, depuis une petite dizaine d'années, sur les réseaux sociaux.
Est-ce qu'il y a pas un problème de désinformation sur les réseaux sociaux vis-à-vis du déficit de l'attention ?
J'adore les réseaux sociaux.
Oui, moi aussi.
J'adore les réseaux sociaux. Y a plein de mes consœurs et confrères qui détestent ça. Oui, bien sûr, y a plein de bêtises qui se racontent sur les réseaux sociaux, plein.
Mais, un, ça permet d'augmenter la prise de conscience de l'existence du TDA. Avec le risque, probablement, parfois de surdiagnostiquer parce qu'on parle justement : « Ah oui, tu n'as pas un TDA, mais tu as des traits de type TDA.
Tu as une personnalité de type TDA. Tu fonctionnes un peu comme un TDA. » Non, c'est un diagnostic médical.
Mmm-hmm.
On a un TDA ou on n'a pas un TDA. Après ça-
Je suis tout à fait d'accord
...c'est comme tous les diagnostics médicaux. Si vous allez voir dix chirurgiens orthopédistes avec
un problème de l'arthrose de la hanche, si neuf vous disent qu'il ne faut pas vous faire opérer, c'est que probablement, il faut pas vous faire opérer, mais il y en a toujours un dixième qui va vous opérer.
Dans le TDA, comme vous le savez, c'est un continuum, euh-
Un spectre
...c'est un spectre. Et on a des cas qui sont limites. Et donc, si on est un petit peu plus carré, on va dire : « Non, pas de TDA, mais voilà ».
Et si on intègre plus dans un fonctionnement global, on va parfois dire : « Oui, je pense que c'est un TDA », alors que d'autres auraient dit non.
Donc, la ligne peut un tout petit peu bouger, mais c'est un petit peu bouger. La majorité des cas sont TDA ou ne sont pas TDA, ont un TDA.
Pas ne sont, pas sont ou ne sont pas d'ailleurs, parce que-
Ah, c'est intéressant ça. C'est très... bon, c'est très politique, ça. C'est très, y a-
Non, parce que la première chose que je dis à mes patients, c'est : « Ne vous essentialisez pas ». Il y a des petits, il y a des grands TDA.
Il y a des TDA chauves comme moi, ils ont beaucoup de chance, et des TDA qui ne sont pas chauves comme vous. Il y a des gens qui adorent la musique, il y a des gens qui détestent la musique.
Il y a des gens qui adorent cuisiner, il y a des gens qui détestent cuisiner. Il y a des gens qui adorent la mécanique, des gens qui détestent la mécanique.
Et donc le TDA est un élément qui va sous-tendre votre fonctionnement, mais ça ne vous définit absolument pas dans votre entièreté de qui vous êtes.
Oui. Après, est-ce qu'être belge vous définit dans votre entièreté de qui vous êtes ? Enfin...
Absolument pas.
Voilà.
Sûrement pas.
Et on vous en parlait au verbe être.
Vous êtes belge, vous n'avez pas une nationalité belge.
Oui, mais dans l'utilisation de la langue française, je ne peux pas dire : « J'ai belge » parce que-
Vous avez une nationalité belge.
J'ai la nationalité belge, c'est ça.
Est-ce que vous êtes... j'ai un trouble du TDA, je suis un TDAH.
Moi, je préfère qu'on dise : « J'ai un TDA » plutôt que « Je suis un TDA ».
C'est vraiment une question très personnelle. Moi, je suis plutôt du côté verbe être, mais surtout quand on parle de trucs neurodéveloppementals, enfin...
Mais vous savez, l'important, c'est que la personne qui est en face de vous se sente bien.
Absolument.
Et si quelqu'un me dit : « De loin, je préfère dire je suis TDA... »
Mmm-hmm.
Magnifique.
Voilà. Et donc juste pour clôturer et pour revenir vite fait sur la question des réseaux sociaux. Ce qui est très évident, c'est que, donc, on le voit, c'est un spectre, donc des expériences très différentes.
Personnes qui vont généraliser leur propre vécu en disant : « Bah quand on a ou quand on est TDA, on a ceci, cela, on a telle expérience, telle expérience ».
Alors que ce n'est pas forcément, en fait, des expériences qui sont liées au trouble en question. Voilà, j'ai en tête, par exemple, un,
une vidéo d'une personne qui expliquait que pour les fêtes, elle avait dû changer très fort sa routine, changer très fort ses habitudes et que c'était très difficile pour elle.
Quand on écoutait ça, bon, moi, j'ai mon radar à autiste qui se déclenchait très très fort en disant : « Bon, ça ressemble quand même à une certaine inflexibilité très autistique ».
Et la personne expliquait que c'était parce qu'elle avait un trouble du déficit de l'attention. On ne voyait pas très bien le rapport, mais c'est comme ça que c'était présenté.
Il y a, oui, beaucoup de mélanges, beaucoup de choses, puisque comme on disait tout à l'heure, les diagnostics peuvent s'empiler.
On peut associer certains traits à un diagnostic qui n'est pas forcément celui qui est le plus pertinent. Et bon...
Oui, oui. Oui, oui, il y a plein de bêtises, on va rester polis, qui se disent sur les réseaux sociaux. Mais d'autre part, pour les patients qui ont la possibilité d'être pris en charge, ça entraîne des discussions-
Voilà, exactement.
...ça anime le débat, ça... Même ChatGPT, vous savez, moi, alors là, je suis très très surpris parce que ça fait quelques mois que j'ai quand même très très régulièrement,
quasi chaque semaine, au moins un patient, que je suis hein, ce n'est pas première consultation, et qui vient me disant : « J'ai posé la question à ChatGPT concernant...
» Voilà. Bah oui, c'est bien. On va en discuter.
Oui, c'est ça. Ça ouvre la discussion. On n'est pas obligé d'être sûr à 100 % d'être concerné avant d'aller voir un médecin.
Parce que le principe, c'est que c'est le médecin qui va nous confirmer ou nous expliquer qu'on n'est pas concerné par le trouble, le cas échéant.
D'ailleurs, c'est une question que je peux vous poser. Est-ce que vous voyez beaucoup de personnes qui ne sont pas concernées par le TDA et qui viennent chercher un diagnostic ?
Est-ce qu'on a un ratio plutôt positif vis-à-vis des personnes qui sont concernées et qui ne sont pas concernées ?
Eh bien, si. Je vous remercie pour la question parce que j'ai passé la majorité de ma vie professionnelle, pour l'instant, à m'occuper de neurologie et de troubles neurodégénératifs, notamment.
D'accord. Alzheimer, par exemple.
Dont la maladie d'Alzheimer. Et là, je m'occupe de troubles neurodéveloppementaux. Beaucoup de patients qui viennent spontanément en consultation de neurologie en disant : « J'ai peur d'avoir un Alzheimer ».
Je n'ai pas de statistiques à vous proposer, mais beaucoup de patients n'ont pas de maladie d'Alzheimer. Et la très grande majorité des gens qui viennent en consultation en disant : « Bonjour,
je pense que j'ai un trouble neurodéveloppemental », parce que c'est tout à fait vrai pour le TSA aussi.
Je pense que j'ai un TDA. Alors, on est loin des cent pour cent, mais dans la grande majorité des cas, ils ont raison.
Là où ils n'ont pas conscience de certaines choses, c'est que très souvent leur TDA n'est pas isolé et leur TDA vient avec autre chose.
D'autres troubles, oui.
Évidemment, on est là pour poser le diagnostic de TDA, mais on est là pour leur parler de l'univers du TDA.
Donc, vous dites que dans la grande majorité des cas, sans donner de chiffres précis, dans la grande majorité des cas, les personnes qui soupçonnent un trouble, voilà, neurodéveloppemental sont généralement, ont raison de le soupçonner.
Oui. Dans certainement quatre-vingts pour cent des cas.
Ah oui, c'est large.
Oui, oui.
Et donc ça infirme complètement cette idée reçue comme quoi ce serait une mode, comme quoi tout le monde pense l'être alors qu'en fait pas du tout.
Puisque concrètement, ce qu'observent effectivement les praticiens comme vous, c'est que c'est véridique.
Le problème n'est pas celui du TDA. Dans TDA, il y a trouble. Dans TSA, il y a trouble. S'il y a trouble, il y a souffrance.
Le problème, c'est celui de la souffrance. Si quelqu'un passe la porte de la consultation et se pose la question d'un TDA ou d'un TSA, ce n'est pas parce que c'est à la mode, c'est parce qu'il souffre.
Mh. Voilà.
Et s'il souffre, c'est que généralement, il a raison. Il y a un truc qui est fondamental : on doit écouter nos patients.
Aujourd'hui, heureusement, j'espère pour tout le monde, l'idée qu'il y a un médecin tout-puissant qui sait tout et qu'il y a un patient faible qui ne sait rien est terminée.
Nous sommes à égalité dans un échange où on a par ailleurs tout à fait le droit de ne pas être d'accord avec son médecin.
Mh.
Sur tout. Et c'est bien.
C'est très intéressant.
On en discute.
C'est très libre-exaministe, finalement, cette idée que l'argument d'autorité de la blouse blanche doit être sérieusement remis en question et qu'on peut choisir d'aller se demander une deuxième opinion si...
Bien sûr. Ah ben alors, certainement.
À titre très personnel, ça m'est tout à fait arrivé, même après mon diagnostic d'autisme, d'avoir des,
des médecins qui m'expliquaient, qui me regardaient un petit peu en doutant, en se disant que c'était pas du tout véridique et que c'était n'importe quoi, etc.
Il faut être en mesure de prendre du recul et de se dire que c'est peut-être le médecin qui n'y connaît rien puisque comme on le disait, au niveau de la formation, c'est absolument catastrophique en Belgique.
Ouais.
Donc voilà.
Je confirme.
Mais ce que vous disiez est en tout cas un message très encourageant vis-à-vis de la légitimité des patients à franchir le pas, de votre, voilà, de votre cabinet ou de celui d'un autre, en cas de difficulté.
C'est une très belle conclusion. Philippe Violon, merci beaucoup pour ce beaucoup plus que Septante Minutes qu'on, que nous avons passés ensemble.
J'ai dû être hyper focus. Merci, merci beaucoup.
Ce fut un plaisir. À très bientôt, au revoir.
À très bientôt, au revoir.
Si vous avez des questions, vous vous interrogez au sujet de vous ou de vos proches vis-à-vis du TDAH ou de la neurodiversité, n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un e-mail.
Je fais ça vraiment avec plaisir. Vous avez compris que c'est très important pour moi. contact@septanteminutes.be.
C'est noté dans la description. contact@septanteminutes.be.
Et voilà, malheureusement,
je ne peux pas vous donner les coordonnées, donc, de Philippe Violon, en particulier parce que, donc, ben concrètement, les listes d'attente sont absolument monstrueuses et que la situation en Belgique, comme on l'a dit, est catastrophique.
Je rappelle aussi, on ne l'a pas dit explicitement, mais ça vaut la peine de le rappeler, que le TDAH et l'autisme ne sont pas des maladies.
Je sais que de temps en temps, il y a parfois des formulations qui laissent un petit peu penser ça, mais je pense que c'est juste une déformation parce que c'est un médecin.
Non, ce ne sont pas des pathologies, ce sont juste des différences, voilà. De la même manière qu'on peut être différent en termes d'identité de genre, d'orientation sexuelle.
Il y a des grands, il y a des petits, il y a des gros, il y a des minces, voilà. Il y a des gens qui sont neurodivergents, il y a des gens qui sont autistes, des gens qui sont TDAH, des gens qui sont anxieux.
C'est juste une façon d'être. Ce ne sont pas des maladies. Et ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'il faut essayer de faire disparaître.
Voilà, je pense par exemple à l'actualité récente aux États-Unis qui est absolument glauque. Je vous rappelle que Septante Minutes Avec est dispo sur toutes les plateformes de podcast, Spotify, Apple Podcast, Pocket Casts.
C'est même dispo sur YouTube en vidéo. Et il y aura dans les semaines à venir, dans les, oui, cinq, six semaines à venir, beaucoup d'épisodes.
J'ai booké pas mal d'interviews. On va essayer d'enchaîner très rapidement puisque j'ai fait une grosse pause, en fait, pour info.
Pour info, j'ai fait une chirurgie le mois dernier, donc j'étais absolument hors service. Mais me voilà à présent de retour afin de, évidemment, vous jouer un mauvais tour et de préserver le monde de la dévastation.
Je vous dis à très bientôt. Salut. Nous sommes de retour.
Pour jouer un mauvais tour.
Afin de préserver le monde de la dévastation.
Afin de rallier tous les peuples à notre nation.
Afin d'écraser l'amour et la vérité.
Afin d'étendre notre pouvoir jusqu'à la Voie lactée.
Jesse.
James.
La Team Rocket, plus rapide que la lumière.
Rendez-vous tous ou ce sera la guerre.
Oui, la guerre !